No follow.
We took three [inaudible]
boom.
And we're live Henry motherfucking pseudo world champ.
And Sir,
introduce yourself to everybody and the captain America.
That's right.
Captain Eric Alibaba seen a Henry's coach.
You,
uh,
what,
what do you do with them specifically?
Well,
I've been with him since 2004 and recently became his coach right before the
first Denise Johnson fine.
And I'm as head coach for Nma and you're in disguise in case some other athletes
try to swipe it and it's Halloween.
Happy Halloween.
Everybody happy the folks.
So,
uh,
first of all,
man,
congratulations on your victory.
Um,
it does it feel like,
oh man,
it's it.
Uh,
it feels good.
It feels good.
Try to keep this silly a fist away from your face.
Uh,
it feels good because it's,
um,
cabinets.
I think as a competitor you,
you live for these moments.
She lived,
you live for these fulfillments,
you know,
I think somebody like,
and then I told people since the beginning,
it wasn't so much,
you know,
the UFC belt,
but it was because it was,
I made it about Demetrius and it was about Demetrius.
You know,
cause he's mean,
he is widely considered to be the best pound for pound fighter ever.
And you're the first guy,
not only to beat him but the first guy who,
not just to beat him but me beat him in like 11 years,
but the first guy to win an Olympic gold medal in wrestling and a UFC
championship.
I mean those are two gigantic accomplishments.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
It's almost like,
ah God,
it's,
I beat the greatest of,
to me the greatest of all time.
And then on top of that I be,
you know,
I can,
I can make the run for,
you know,
who's the greatest combat athlete of all time?
Like it's a,
I'm a two sport world champion.
I'm just like,
Damn.
I mean you're absolutely in the running now.
I mean if,
if he's not the greatest of all time,
I think he is,
but the argument is that he didn't face people as good as John Jones faced and
then fade or is the other fade or an Anderson silver or the other people that
are in consideration for the greatest of all time.
I mean,
it's,
it's just a subjective argument.
I mean,
who,
who knows who's right,
but obviously you beat without a doubt one of the best ever.
Yeah.
And like I would,
I would tell people there's,
there's a bit of a of admiration that I had for Demetrius Johnson.
Like I was,
uh,
it was,
it was like,
you know,
you're fighting the dude that's,
that's,
that almost seems untouchable that you,
a guy that makes you question yourself.
Like,
Whoa,
this is,
this is this,
this guy's that good.
Well,
what's crazy is you beat him after he had stopped you.
Just how,
how long was it?
Two years.
Ah,
but close to about two and a half years ago now.
Yeah.
About,
I was like,
I think two years and like four months.
That's,
that's an amazing turnaround between getting stopped in the first round and then
coming back and beating him and beating him in the championship rounds is really
where you pulled it off.
Yeah,
yeah,
no,
that,
absolutely.
I
had studied Demetrius Johnson like I seen as a lost son the first time would,
I pretty much did is I got,
I got rid of a lot of people,
including my,
my MMA had coach.
I just,
my whole philosophy was,
if I can't be the best and there's something wrong,
you know,
emotionally,
physically,
everything else just invested.
And when I lost,
I'm just like,
man,
I need to,
I,
I'm looking for a better leader,
you know?
And,
and that's kind of what I did.
I ended up,
you know,
letting go a lot of my cornerman can,
I started traveling the world.
W went out to Singapore,
we're now to Wa to Thailand.
Went out to,
uh,
to the Netherlands,
spend months and months at a time out in Brazil.
Like I,
uh,
I was on a quest that was like the,
I kind of remind myself,
literally like,
ash catch him from Pokemon.
Like,
I was just on a venture dude,
I have no idea who that is.
The vision called vision quest.
It was Matthew Modine mood swing swing has to watch that movie
and that's,
and,
and it'd be,
like I said,
it became an obsession.
I,
I knew that if anybody could do it,
it'd be,
it'd be Hennish the Hudl,
like I really did.
And you even after the first time,
Jill,
when he beat me,
I still,
when they asked me,
he's like,
Henry,
you know,
like I would,
I was like,
guys,
I don't know,
but I still know that I could beat him even being knocked out like two minutes
and 36 seconds.
Like I still knew in my heart.
Uh,
UFC one,
I sat there press conferences.
I know I'm still the one that beat him.
What was it about
him that made you think that you could beat him?
What was it about you specifically in relation to him and his skill set?
It was a,
um,
I,
if you're asking me what the difference,
what was it that made you think even after he stopped you in the first round?
Oh God.
Uh,
I think it was more so just believing in my,
in my abilities.
I think me just believe in Mora.
Okay.
Henry,
you need time.
Like I was only doing MMA for three years when I fought him the first time.
Yeah.
A lot of people don't know that year's you see you fighting for the title.
Not once,
but twice.
The price probably been doing MMA for a long ass time.
But when you find them for the first time,
it's a very,
that's a very short amount of time to be finding an MMA.
It's especially again to caliber athletic.
Demetrius,
what year did you win the Olympics and,
oh wait,
yeah,
see that is,
I mean when you're doing that,
you're 100% dedicated to wrestling.
You have to be,
right.
So were you doing any striking training at all back then?
Um,
did I did,
what happened was once I won the Olympics,
almost kind of,
I fell out of love with the sport.
I fell,
I fell out of love with Russ.
And I remember being at the Olympics and being like,
man,
I just,
I don't know if I have it in me no more just cause you're burnt out.
I was,
yeah,
my whole childhood was gone because of the sport.
Take that crazy mask off.
Part of that.
What are you doing?
I mean I've been waiting for you to say that.
We'll do it in stages.
So you,
you,
you fell out of love with it.
I fell out of love with it.
Which is,
which is it?
Just because your whole life had been dedicated to wrestling and you'd finally
achieved the greatest of great goals.
Yeah.
Olympic gold medalist is the top of the mountain.
No,
but check this out Joe.
And it was like in the year of 2007,
um,
man,
I went through the worst year ever.
Like,
I was ready to become a world champion and I went out to the world champions in
2007 and I didn't even score a point.
I can the first round,
like I got put out by Bite Juran and a for somebody in that whole year,
man,
I was just going through freaking struggles like left and right.
You're talking about just that versus I couldn't want to turn him in to save my
life.
What was it?
Um,
I don't know.
I truly,
truly don't know.
I think I was,
uh,
I think I probably begin kind of fallen out of love with it.
And I remember there was,
to me,
there was only two tournaments that everyone has to win and that was,
that was the Olympic trials and eventually the Olympic Games and,
and somehow like,
cause I'm correlating this with the,
with the fight with Demetrius Johnson and uh,
I remember,
you know,
just,
just almost being in tears.
Like I just don't know if this is for me and the,
but I just stuck with it.
I stuck with it.
I ended up putting the Olympic trials.
I ended up going to the,
you know,
the Olympic Games and I ended up pretty much fallen behind in every single
match,
uh,
that I was wrestling.
So the,
these are kind of the adversities that I was going through,
like leading up to become an Olympic champion.
You know,
it's interesting when you were fighting,
um,
Demetrius for the second time,
Daniel Cormier,
some said something very interesting.
He said,
most guys,
he goes,
I would never give a chance.
You,
you get stopped by Dj.
And then a couple of years later you're fighting him again.
Like he's,
he's going to have your number,
he's going to be better in the rematch.
And he goes,
but Henry,
so who knows,
a different kind of athlete.
He,
and he talked about you competing and then coming back a year later and,
and being,
he goes,
he was many times better.
He goes,
the,
the amount of improvement that he got in just one year was just unbelievable.
Yeah.
And I think,
you know,
I guess she could know that teaching netics I think you could talk a lot about
desire to just having the sex only get you so far.
The Olympics has,
has g great genetics for sure.
But it's almost,
it almost becomes a,
uh,
a mentality.
I'm because of a philosophy.
It's like you almost start doing things almost like two to not feel that,
to not to not feel the pain of losing.
Hmm.
Like that's a motivator to not feel the pain of losing.
And I remember when Demetrius Johnson hit me,
hit me and hit me in the leg and I literally,
I don't think you put your,
how severe it was.
Like I literally spraying like a,
a severe low ankle sprain in those first 30 seconds in the second fight.
So I fought Demetrius Johnson like that.
But it was,
it was,
to me the motivator was like,
man,
I don't want to feel that pain of losing more.
I hate it man.
I hate feeling second place.
I hate feeling Kinda,
kinda somewhat.
He's looking over me.
Someone's a almost like a manhood cha and I hate that.
Was it a low leg kick that been made your,
your ankle go?
Like what was it?
It was a,
there's a nerve that you have behind La,
like the bonus up PR,
I think it's the brand peripheral peripheral nerve p.
E.
R.
Yeah.
And I got hit there so I put my foot to sleep just like when Michael Chandler,
it happened to him in Beltour.
Same thing.
Exactly.
Stepping on it and it's just not working.
And the pro and the reason,
these reasons why everybody kind of got scared.
I mean cause I was,
I was hurt,
but I remember before the fight,
I remember,
I remember I saw my cornerman like kind of wait for,
I fought the meters.
I remember I saw him all.
Ah,
I saw him on nervous and never see,
I remember grabbing my cornerman is putting them right in front of me.
I remember telling him,
I said,
hey guys,
I've been here before.
Like I was ranked 31st in the world.
I'd be,
I know,
I,
I became a world champion in wrestling.
Like guys,
like,
yeah,
I want you guys to have a little faith in the deed,
but I'm going to ask you guys one thing and I'm going to ask you guys,
I'm going to ask you guys to be composed.
I said,
the key to winning this fight is for me to be composed.
And then pretty much there's six hours later,
they,
uh,
right before,
you know,
walk on the start playing my song.
I looked back at my corner and I said,
uh,
and I said,
guys,
I said,
the key to this fight,
remember I said it'd be composure.
So when Denesha Johnson kicked me,
like I,
I believe in my own philosophy,
I went back to,
all right,
my composure because I was hurt.
Y'All.
Like he could have stopped me that,
that first round I was forced to switch south South Paul,
which had never fight in South Pole,
you know,
so now we're kind of,
I worked with me and Demetrius Johnson or playing poker,
my whole philosophy and the key to this victory was a composure part.
And,
uh,
when he hit me,
I,
uh,
I really did.
I was like,
oh my God,
not again did not again,
I'm not going to last two minutes and 36 seconds.
Not Again,
but it again,
the motivator was not to feel the pain to lose again.
Like it wasn't a desire to win.
I was like,
I just don't want to feel that pain anymore as a competitor,
as somebody that,
that,
that that's on a mission to that sacrifices life.
Explain to someone who's never experienced that before.
What is that pain like?
You train for how many weeks and then you find mighty mouse with the title.
You get stopped in the first round.
What does our pain La man,
it's,
I think every fighter has a spirit.
Like what is the spirit?
The spirit is your spirit.
Is your dream.
This bird is that,
that you know,
you've watched somebody become a world champion.
You want to be,
hey,
I want to be just like that guy.
Your confidence,
your self esteem.
That's,
that's your spirit and you will also,
we also have a spirit of a war that's like the,
the man has side of it.
And what happens when I got stopped with Demetrius Johnson to,
I almost felt like,
and I've never gone through this,
not even in wrestling my life like ours,
like my spirit was shot and I had to kind of pick up my pieces to kind of start
healing myself.
Like mentally and I feel like it,
and if,
if
you look at a Joe with somebody like Roy Jones jr he got knocked out one time
and it became a domino effect.
Yeah.
Because he never,
he never picked off those pieces.
He never started healing that spirit.
Well,
he got knocked down again real bad right afterwards by Glen Johnson to members.
There's two,
two knockouts in a row.
Tarver Tarver k Odom and then [inaudible].
But the thing is,
there's a lot of factors involved in that loss because I think Roy was also
coming off of the John Ruiz fight where he gained a lot of weight to get up to
heavyweight,
and then he had to lose that weight to get down the light heavyweight again.
So he was lean at heavyweight and then all of a sudden he's dropping down to 175
pounds again.
And he just looked like,
shit,
it looks smooth.
It looked like his body was all sucked in and I just think it was a bad,
bad weight cut.
And you know,
I think whatever he took to get himself up to 200 pounds to it was probably out
of its system.
And now his body was,
you know,
his hormones were probably all fucked up.
He just wasn't the same guy.
I mean,
it's,
let's be real,
right?
The weekends,
it's important.
You don't just grow the 200 pounds without some Mexican supplements.
This like,
you know what I'm saying?
I mean,
it'll take a long fucking time for 168 pound fighter to get up to 200 pounds.
It takes a long time.
If you want to really get up to 200 pounds,
like a,
an actual 200 pound body,
not just like fill yourself up with water and fat.
No.
Did to actually be 200 pounds of way he was,
your body's got to,
your body's got to say,
hey man,
we need to fucking grow.
We got resources that need to be allocated towards muscle.
We've got to,
we've got to gain all this weight because w we're lifting weights all the time.
We're doing things.
You have to do something to get your body that heavy so that and then all of a
sudden it shut that shit off and say,
right now we're getting down to one 75 and you've got to do it in a few months.
I think his body was just wrecked.
Yeah.
Boxes don't always cut weight the right way either.
Neither do I may fighters.
Oh,
particularly back in the day there's,
which is really interesting about the approach that you guys took to this camp
that you wanted to talk about,
which is a very,
very scientific approach towards your recovery towards training methods.
So it's everything.
I mean,
you,
you really had it dialed in as opposed to just trying to wing it,
which for many,
many years was how almost every fight or did it.
Yeah,
and I think it's a how,
oh,
we got a video.
Look at this.
I found that part.
We got kicked and you can see like,
oh,
okay.
So
it was right there.
Just the back of the leg like that.
That is so crazy.
Just one shin to the mat.
I still fly.
I'm still flopping.
Yeah.
So I'm going back to that philosophy.
Composure.
Look,
I'm still flopping,
but it doesn't seem like he understands what's happened to you yet.
Yeah.
You know,
you're,
you,
you played poker so well.
Yeah.
Really interesting.
Look,
I'm still,
oh,
oh.
As soon as that happened,
I did remember the Michael Chandler fight and I remember he went on a show and
said exactly what happened.
So I told uh,
our other corners Santina the frank and when we get in,
put ice on his knee,
not his ankle because it was the where it happened.
Cause I watched that show and I remember watching it for that reason,
to wonder why,
what happened to them.
It's crazy when you watch it because it's just the foot hit the back of your
knee.
Yeah.
You know?
Yeah,
you can see it again.
I mean it wasn't even the hardest kick in the world.
He kind of caught you at the very end with his foot and immediately that nerve,
just one [inaudible] right here.
Swap worked right there.
Hey,
barely
know.
You know who it also happened to was a Scott Jorgenson did it won't fight.
Was that man,
you know what?
I can't remember,
but he didn't win the fight.
I can tell you that.
Yeah.
Anyways,
it was a terrible feeling.
Terrible,
terrible feeling.
Well you poker face your way through it.
But again,
Joe,
like it goes back to philosophy.
Like you got to believe in your,
you gotta,
you gotta be up here.
There has to be a philosophy,
a period against a guy like the meat.
She was like,
there's the,
it's,
it's beyond the physical and the technical stuff.
Yeah.
Like you gotta be,
you gotta be just kind of hit Matteis the up here.
Well,
you have to have everything,
right?
You have to have the physical skills,
but you also have to have this an unstoppable mindset.
Yeah.
Now what do you,
what kind of mind training do you do?
Do you,
do you do any visualization training or do you work with a sports psychologist
or,
um,
do you know what I,
uh,
I like,
I like reading up on a lot of people stores.
I think people's stores are the ones that are,
that intrigued me.
You know,
how,
you know how Michael Jordan Rose to the top or,
uh,
at least like that I think.
I think that's the stuff that I,
uh,
I got like a human interest.
That's kind of my motivation.
Like reading biographies,
reading biographies,
or watching,
watching stuff on Youtube,
like,
uh,
you know,
watching him,
I gave him watching even watching other sports,
like I'll,
I'll watch Michael Johnson's at,
at times,
you know,
wha watching them one than 96 Olympics,
like things like that.
And,
and watching people celebrations and,
and uh,
and tried to embrace the feeling of,
of what they're feeling,
you know,
cause it,
it becomes like an addiction,
like a drug,
like going through these feelings of like,
did I accomplish what I,
what I,
what I set out to do.
Right.
So you like seeing them accomplish these fantastic goals and visualizing
yourself experiencing that exact same thing.
Yeah.
As corny as that sounds.
Doesn't sound corny at all.
Especially not coming from the champ.
You know,
once you're the champ,
all that corny shit's out.
The window works.
People start believing it.
Uh,
all of a sudden I became a 10.
Yeah.
They believe the fuck out of it.
Now they're talking about you possibly fighting Tj Dillashaw for the
bantamweight title.
Uh,
yeah.
My name is Tom.
Just talk,
you know,
you just hesitated and you,
they come on,
there's negotiations,
there's a BC high and that it's not just tough.
He wants it.
We want it.
Yeah.
I'm sure.
Um,
where's that at right now?
Because a,
there's a,
there's going to be a card in January out here and it was just announced.
Oh Wow.
When did,
uh,
what,
what date was that?
It's the same night as the fade or Ryan Bader fight,
which pisses me off because I wanted to go see that fight.
Yeah.
January 26.
That fight is going to be at the forum and the,
a UFC fight I think is at the staple center or maybe Anaheim.
Anaheim,
Anaheim in the pond.
Oh,
okay.
Both of here.
Both here in California.
Well,
just 20 million motherfuckers in California.
Plenty of people that go around.
Yeah.
Terms of audience.
We've,
we've,
uh,
I think there's been talks,
but it's been,
you know,
we,
I don't think Ali,
my manager has really truly like actually sat down and talk with the UFC,
I think.
I think everybody wants to do it though.
Well,
it's one of two things is going to happen there,
right?
It's either,
um,
I mean now the DJ has gone to one.
Um,
Demetrius Johnson just left the UFC and went over to one FC in a one fc for
people who have no idea what we're talking about is a gigantic organization in
Asia.
They are literally the equivalent to the UFC in Asia.
And although many people in America are not aware of them,
they don't know who they are.
They're a huge organization overseas,
absolutely gigantic.
And they do a fantastic job.
They have real high level fighters.
Uh,
Ben asked her and was their champion.
He was undefeated over there and he had I think at least one fight,
maybe two fights left in his contract.
I forget how many,
and they made a deal and the deal was they take mighty mouse and we get Ben ass
grin.
And so that's where it's at right now.
I love the deal.
I love it.
I love the idea of it.
I mean,
um,
I feel like mighty mouse,
you know,
he,
um,
he loves the idea of starting new in a new organization.
And you know,
they're going to hey,
that motherfucker,
hey,
nice.
Yeah.
All these fly with and to get paid.
Exactly.
And he also likes the mentality that that organization is operated with,
which is,
um,
respect for the martial arts.
They're not into this,
you know,
what we saw with the Conor McGregor could,
could be a number of Madoff fired,
all the trash talking and all the,
all the stuff that you're seeing that was becoming more and more prevalent in
the UFC.
You,
uh,
you don't see that at all at one FC.
And that's something that a mighty mouse,
very happy.
Yeah.
I think first,
I think congratulations to,
to Ben Astro and I think he's a,
yeah.
Everybody's in trouble.
Yeah.
It's a lot of mother fuckers are in trouble and Penn asking if the whole view,
you're like,
why can't I get up?
Yeah.
Bet.
But Nashville is one of those guys that he's very,
uh,
he's a very confident,
he's a very dangerous human mean because he knows that he's going to be very
confident about it.
Yeah.
And,
um,
I've always told people,
I says,
hey dude,
maybe the best in the world is on the UFC.
Man.
There's,
there's some do.
But I ain't even been asked when we met him.
He prays for years.
That will take people think could be as a control is good up top.
You wait till you get a,
you know,
for time NCAA finalist to time and see a chap on top of you that the 2008 in
Olympia and his teammates yet.
And Andy Olympian,
I mean the dude is,
that dude is,
he's a bad matchup for anybody,
Joe.
Anyway,
no,
Ben ask her.
And I mean there's a reason why he's undefeated and he hasn't been hit in
several fights.
Who was detailing one of the last time we got hit,
you know,
I had him on the podcast because I wanted to let people know about them.
I mean,
I've been a big fan of bay fan of Ban aspirins from back when he was a belt or
champion.
And if you watch his fights and belt or against chorus cough and yeah,
and Lima Lima's a beast man.
And he just dominated them.
Just controlling the Lima fucks people up,
man.
Lima's a dangerous,
dangerous Kat.
And Ben asked grinches whoop,
Oh,
you're on your back again.
Look at that.
Yeah,
you can't get up and you taking punches,
you know?
And he's a,
it's a just a different caliber of wrestling.
And I've said it many,
many times and I bet,
I'm sure you believe it as well.
It's the most important skill for MMA.
Wrestling.
It's,
it dictates where the fight takes place.
If you want to stand up,
you get,
the guy can take you down chuck Liddell style.
And if you want to go to the ground,
you're the one who gets to dictate where the fight takes place.
That's if you're the superior wrestler.
I mean,
it's the best base for MMA.
I really believe that.
And especially a guy like banks,
I think Ben knows that his,
his strikings not that good.
Right?
So he just relies on this is,
this is what I know I do a better than anybody and I'm going to control this and
you're going to know how I'm going to do it.
You know?
So that's what,
that's what makes been asking.
He's so dangerous.
I mean a real bad fight for him would be someone that can figure out how to keep
it standing.
Like Jay hair on gave him a real tough fight and Bella tour,
cause Jay Hiran is good wrestler and kept the fight standing high school.
I forget what his,
what his take on that fight was.
We talked about it on the podcast,
but I don't think he was too happy with his training for that fight.
But you know,
someone like Tyron Woodley who's also a very good wrestler who's a very
dangerous striker would be a tough match up for them.
But they're really front close friends and training partners.
Yeah.
Well this is another thing too on the flip side is like a,
Taryn has been wrestling him since for years I think.
So he knows what the Ben Ashkan experiences,
you know,
and that's scary.
Yeah.
I mean people would be lucky to,
you know,
kind of take them down if you really want to give it a no take downs.
He wouldn't,
he just wouldn't let people take them down.
Yeah.
Paris was talking about it,
you know,
he's saying,
listen,
it was back when Paris was the champ.
He said if I was forced to fight Ben ass and he goes,
it would be a fucking terrible fight from me.
He's like,
that guy just take me down and beat the shit out of me.
that's what he does then was to win a belt.
The 2008 Olympic team would have five belts.
Henry gets to DC,
has to and and uh,
Ben Asca and we'd have one that's five belt.
If,
if he came into the UFC and won the belt,
his teammates,
well they are going to open up eventually that 165 pound division,
which is what Ben is shooting for.
Ben would like that division.
Um,
you know,
and if he said that,
if you know,
he had one 65 and tire and kept the welterweight title,
that would be great for him.
I just don't see the UFC doing a five pound weight difference when all the other
weight differences are so huge.
I feel like the smart move would be 10 pounds every,
every spot.
35455560570 five like move 70 to 75 like when the UFC had a light heavyweight
division initially that the division was a 200 pound division.
When Tito Ortiz first one and I believe it was 200 pound division,
and then they raise it up to two oh five and I think just in,
they needed a one 95 too.
I really believe,
and it probably a two 25 you know,
I think that would,
that would round it all out,
which probably will all happen eventually.
Yeah.
It's,
that's interesting to see how that,
how that unfolds.
But as of now,
it's man Ashkin,
she's a beast.
She's going to be fighting for the belt.
Pretty silly.
Well,
he's calling out Darren till he wants to fight Darren,
which I love.
I love that.
That is,
that is a classic striker versus grappler match up,
especially after tiring.
Just smashed him.
I mean,
Tyron and the hype train for Darren till we,
we learned a lot about Darren.
Darren is a sensational striker,
very,
very dangerous striker,
but keeps his hands low,
keeps his chin up high.
And you know,
Tyron has proved himself to be really dangerous even against elite strikers.
You know,
you look at the Wonderboy fights,
I've said this time and time again,
you look at those two fights.
Wonderboy is known as being one of the best strikers to ever compete in the UFC.
He's got a crate,
I think it was 57 and o was a kickbox or something fucking spectacular like
that.
Amazing striking skills.
But yet Tyron hurt him in both fights,
both fights.
Tyron was the one who landed big shots and had Wonderboy badly hurt.
And then you look at the same thing with Darren till Darren tills known as being
this unbelievable striker.
Tyron clips him,
drops him,
and then strangles him.
So you know,
it,
it all changes with MMA.
These guys can beat these guys can be the best,
even the best wrestlers.
Like sometimes it,
it doesn't translate to those sport.
Like it takes a special somebody to adapt to the sport of MMA,
not just a rustler.
Yup.
And I think Tyron has has adapted to his time,
to his right hand.
Uh,
you know,
man,
if you're able to take out two strikers,
you like that about you're the real deal.
He's on your unquestionably the real deal deal.
I'm fascinating to see whether or not Norma Medoff and um,
then grin go at it.
Got To me,
I had a fight that I really,
why did you sign in Floyd Mayweather for stop all that nonsense.
I,
this is just what we were talking about is not going to happen.
He has the same age.
Yeah.
Listen,
that ain't going to happen,
but it could be as much more of a grab where the needs are.
Then he is a striker.
I mean Connor is a striker that that's sort of made sense.
If you want to talk about levels.
I think a Benz,
I think Ben said barbecue
better.
The better grappler wound.
The fuck knows.
That's what I want to see.
No,
I want to see that.
But there's,
there's Lavalle was like,
even though like they don't give black belts in Ruskin.
There's,
there's,
there's lab was too,
and I think I've been asking,
it was one of the greatest folks.
Dot Writers of all time.
Like that's how dangerous he is.
He's putting the best,
the best kids in the world and pretzels and submissions,
they just wouldn't get out of,
is it,
he's like a bowl constricted.
Well he's,
he's
dunning in his ability to control guys.
Like you're like,
what the fuck man?
Like chorus golf,
I mean,
and Lima are two great examples cause you look at those guys and Bella tour and
they'd just smash people.
But to Korskoff has one of the craziest spinning back kick knockouts I've ever
seen in my life.
He sent this dude flying through the air.
Do you see that?
A couple of fights ago and the Grand Prix
fucking nasty.
He hits this dude is spinning back kick and literally like launches them into
space and then smashes him when he goes down to the ground.
I mean you look at what lean has been able to do to people when the Roy
MacDonald fight was a very close fight.
Look at this,
watch this.
Look at this.
Boom.
He lost that too.
Is that in Boise?
I don't know where that was,
but so Koresh cough,
you know,
if you watched the Korotkoff fight with,
with Ben Aspirin and it's a mauling,
it's,
it's just a guy just getting fucked up.
That's what that fight is.
Oh God.
Ben Asked her and just dominated him,
like absolutely dominated them.
See,
the dude tried to jump back and landed.
It landed right as he was in the air out.
She Wauwatosa.
Yeah.
And No.
And Ben and this guy never got a punch off of it.
It was,
it was a total domination.
Same as the Lima fight.
Lima crushes people.
Man.
Liam is one of the scariest strikers.
I mean,
and he knocked out Korskoff.
Lima smashes people.
But you see Lima against Ben [inaudible].
I mean,
obviously it was a younger Lima.
I mean he's got more experienced now,
but the difference was so stunning.
What do you,
what is this?
Saskatoon.
Lima.
No,
it's not.
no.
It was a two Chinese guys,
Bro.
This is not an Oscar in Lima.
You gotta trust me.
This is not asking leamy either.
Title.
I'm sure the videos,
but I'm saying it was Joe being a bully.
You got to trust me.
And then
those dudes are not the same guys.
Joe,
you lose your patience.
There it is.
Oh yeah man.
I mean just the way he manhandled him,
like his wrestling is just,
you see guys that are used to defending takedowns and then they find on their
back and you say,
Holy Shit Man.
I think he did get up kicked here and his nose got broken.
Yeah,
he got cracked.
I mean he blamed us a fucking monster man.
And He's a super dangerous striker and he's huge for the weight class.
You stand next to Lima,
you like Jesus.
How do you make one 70?
He's straight.
He doesn't end up in the Jacuzzi at the hotel.
I've seen him.
Yeah,
no,
he's,
he's struggling to make that weight.
He's a big guy.
But anyway,
point being Ben Aspirin,
uh,
at one 70 super,
super interesting fight.
I would like to the person that the fight that I would like to see,
I like to see him and uh,
him and Colby.
Colby,
Covington,
Ben and cobit.
Yeah.
That would be really interesting.
Yeah,
I think but isn't Colby next in line for the title?
I mean I think he's got the interim belt.
If he has the interim bell surprise.
I'm surprised it's still the White House
White House.
He doesn't have it anymore and sit in the White House.
But I mean did they didn't strip him?
Did they,
cause there was some talk of stripping him because he was supposed to.
He not that I know of.
I don't think there was ever a strip.
So I think there,
I think I tried to market.
So I think as soon as you get the champ,
Wikipedia here says he was the interim from June 9th to September 8th.
Oh.
So they did strip them also.
They did show the stripping was because they wanted him to fight on the Darren
till card.
When Darren till fought Tyron,
they wanted him to fight Tyron and apparently he had gone through,
you know,
hard training camp.
He was all busted up.
He needed time to recover.
So I guess they stripped him that old man.
Interim titles,
interim titles are like attached with Velcro.
They just disappear.
They get yanked off you.
They're not,
they're not really,
they're not really like,
especially at UCT 29.
I mean they all had belts,
stuff Tony Ferguson had about Connor had about,
you know,
obviously it could be that his bells,
we had three people walking around.
I was at the Tony Ferguson one to me is a,
is a shame.
It's a shame that a guy gets injured and then they strip him like that.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
I didn't like that one.
That one bothered me.
Uh,
I feel like Tony should still have the interim title.
I really do it.
But that was like the third time.
Then fine half had fine.
I know it sucks,
but the other one wasn't his fault.
The other one was Khabib.
Khabib,
right.
It could be was supposed to make the weight and he,
you know,
he got to the one medically cold argument
could be pulled out and how many times Tony pull out.
So we pulled out once for sure because he was injured.
The last one when the,
his knee blew apart and then Khabib definitely got yanked off the card one.
It was called the weight.
The weight cut.
Remember the weight cut was so bad that his kidneys were failing.
Yeah.
Either way we've been there.
That's the fight.
No.
Do you,
do you like fighting at 35?
Cause I know you fought it 35 for a while when you were struggling to make
flyweight you ha you had some issues early on in your career when you really
didn't make the weight very well.
Yeah.
It was a god I was,
I was getting older I think in my career.
I think the reason why I started having a weight problem was because of,
uh,
I was just getting older and I was doing some crazy stuff.
Like I used to code like this microphone up like I used to.
I used to,
I used to to cut a bus 16 pounds,
like in and a two,
two hour sessions.
Wow.
Yeah.
As a,
as,
as a flyaway are supposed to be fly away.
Why are you doing that?
Because I felt like it because I'm a rustler.
I think,
uh,
my f my whole philosophy at first when I,
when I got into MMA,
um,
was kinda like I and Russell,
we would never get the same recovery.
I know it's stupid,
as stupid as heck,
but we wouldn't,
we would,
we would never get the recovery that a fire gets.
So to,
to me was like,
dude,
I can,
I can stretch this as a,
as long as I can and,
and,
and I can suffer the day of wins,
but I'm gonna recover within 24,
20,
28 hours sometimes,
you know?
So to me,
I tell was looking at it at a very,
just that an odd way.
And then finally sort started catching up to me.
So you just had confidence in your body's ability to bounce back,
even though you're putting it through an extraordinary amount of stress in
losing massive amounts of weight really quickly.
Yeah.
You just felt like your body can handle it.
You're tough.
You're used to it.
Yeah,
it was,
it was the whole,
cause you know,
in wrestling we would make weight like every,
uh,
every,
every week,
sometimes even Russell so much that we're,
we're used to kind of like that whole,
that whole struggle side of things.
And then,
okay,
we,
Russell game would do it again.
What kind of wake up we were talking about when you were wrestling,
how much were you cutting?
Um,
um,
and that was a lot more discipline then,
but I was probably doing about 12 pounds,
but I had no fat like at that,
at that time I was eating just as healthy and as clean as possible because I
would make weight
every,
you know,
every three weeks I had to tournament,
I had George Lockhart on and he was explaining to me that a lot of people think
that when you cut weight that you know,
like you're cutting out fat.
He's like,
you're not cutting out fat,
you're cutting out water.
And it actually helps to,
to have more muscle because muscles most of your water,
so you're just draining out your muscles.
Then replenishing them.
You know,
when he was explaining that to me,
I was like,
oh,
I never really thought about it that way.
But like a guy like a Yoel Romero who's a very muscular can actually cut more
weight.
Yeah.
Now you're a pretty muscular guy for a flyweight.
So you were walking around how many pounds over?
Oh Man,
I was,
I was probably cutting for like maybe 20,
25.
Wow.
So you're walking around like one 50,
I'm getting down to 25.
Holy Shit.
I just,
I just had lost,
you know,
a lot of the to you,
uh,
because you fight three times a year.
Like you're not always,
you're not always honest with your diet either.
You know,
come from coming from Mexican December,
we liked to,
we love to eat.
You go to my mom's house and it's,
it's going to be laid down.
But when you're in camp,
um,
how do you organize your nutrition?
I'm disciplined.
I have a,
I have a meal prep company.
They deliver my food like every three,
every three days.
And as your meal prep based on your suggestions to them or your recommendations
and directions to them?
Yeah,
no,
a lot of is spaced on kind of,
well,
uh,
my diet's just according to kind of like my training schedule.
So my training is very,
very organized.
Like now,
Joe,
I'm like a,
a pretty much a mom.
I'm a,
I'm a professional now,
I guess you could say like I do things,
you know,
the right way.
I used the whole scientific crowd,
the nutrition route.
It's just a,
uh,
almost like how Bernard Hopkins kind of as he got older men,
he kind of changed his whole philosophy,
started using science more.
So I think everything now in my life when I get ready for fights is all based on
a saw based on science.
How did Bernard changes training?
Do you know?
Um,
he's,
he,
he just started recovering more.
I think he started using a lot of those neural stems.
Um,
a hyperbaric chambers think things of that matter.
Things are that matter and just more scientific based,
like just this whole training all like all around.
And did you incorporate any of those methods?
I did.
I did actually.
I ended up,
uh,
you know,
connecting with this saw connecting with this company called Neuro for Swan,
science space company.
And I actually wanted to bring them meant to kind of,
to kind of talk about it.
She'll,
because this right here and I just changed my whole philosophy.
We're talking about the whole week because how the whole,
wait,
wait.
Cause how I struggled tool to how my whole training has changed because of,
because of,
because of science.
A science that's very,
uh,
that uh,
science that's very,
uh,
I guess complex.
You could say you got have like the right people,
man,
like dictating your schedule.
So when you set up a training camp like this,
how far in advance do you sit down and work out all the details?
It's almost like the,
the morning that we wake up is what we know we're going to do.
But how it,
like say if you know you have a fight in July,
when would you start preparing for that and when do you sit down and map
everything out?
Well we tried to map things out maybe about three months in advance.
Kind of like a preparation and two leading to the camp.
And that's kind of like the phase that we're on now.
Like now we're on,
you know,
if I fight,
if it is at that fight in January,
it's almost like our schedule.
It's like there,
there's,
there's a pretest to the big test.
So tomorrow's November 1st so if you were getting ready for a fight in January,
you would start ramping up somewhere around now.
Yeah.
But it would,
it would,
it would it be more of a,
yeah,
it would.
I think the first,
the first month leading up to the next eight weeks would be,
a lot of it would be a technical and tactical,
just working on those particular areas that we're,
that we believe we're going to be in.
So you're not doing anything crazy.
Strength and conditioning wise,
you're not trying to break your body down.
No,
no it could because it's all,
it's all a learning phase at that point.
You know,
working the body gate,
preparing the body with a lot of body motion movements and things of that
matter.
Kind of just bringing more circulation to certain parts of my body.
Then it rather than,
you know,
somebody picking up a kettle bell and thrown it and,
and,
and crazy things like that.
Like I get it.
It's all,
it's all sports specific,
Brian.
Right.
Range of emotion.
So how do you organize this?
Like kind of what,
what is the team of people that you use and like who's responsible for what?
Yeah,
we'll,
like I said,
I think because you got a whole crew in the back of the mat,
the Lipton America's with you,
but you get,
you get the rest of the Avengers are all waiting in the waiting room.
The effort.
I was gonna say,
we first found him when,
uh,
he hurt his hand and he had to rehab it.
Let me get this off.
Oh,
see it's going in layers just go in.
And so he had heard his hand before
or,
uh,
um,
he,
his first fight with Sergio Pettis and I was trying to find any way for him to
still compete and we found somebody using this machine,
which led us to actually neuro force one and Kareem and all these guys.
And we tried to force it for him to get back in time.
And I have video of him just screaming in pain trying to get there.
And we thought we stayed off it for a couple of weeks and then the day of the
face off he wanted to cut weight and he said his risk kept slipping out.
And we had a poem from the five of you wanted to see the doctor.
Doctor says,
no way.
Shouldn't fight.
So what was the injury?
Uh,
I think it was,
uh,
an ended up being something with sprains ligament.
Yeah.
I think it was a ad spraying like,
uh,
one of my ligaments in my hand.
So there's just,
there's nothing I could do.
Like I would,
I would,
I would open the cap bottle for the,
for,
you know,
to kind of have to brush my teeth and uh,
when it hurt to that point,
I'm just like,
man,
I,
I can't do anything.
So then I that,
you know,
I ended up,
they ended up,
Eric here ended up connecting me with,
with neuro force and found out that they had like these certain machines that
help you heal faster.
And what did the machines do?
Accelerated recovery.
So it was like neuro stem and they have about a thousand programs on it.
And they're just forced him to,
to recover a lot faster.
The best example was UFC fighter Panto Xia he was on the ultimate fighter 24
with us.
Our number one seed that we picked,
Alexander Pintos Tosha.
I saw him blow three ligaments out of his elbow and he started crying cause he
had a fight in eight weeks and iron,
no Scotland.
And um,
I said,
no,
don't go home tomorrow.
He's supposed to be going back home to Brazil.
And I said,
no,
let's try this.
You gotta try it.
And they did it twice,
two sessions a day for 10 days.
And he went back and he,
and he fought,
he fought that guy and beat him.
He rear naked choke and they guy Neil Siri and put that guy in retirement.
So after that I was like,
would it,
we need these guys,
Henry,
whatever these guys did depend Tosha,
whatever that we need to do for you
got started.
When a guy gets injured like that and you're still going through camp,
how do you work around that injury?
You just say,
okay,
news,
nothing squeezing,
nothing.
Where are you putting any strain in those tendons?
Nothing.
Or you're doing anything with that hand that's going to reinjure it.
I think you just have to hope for somebody or rapid very well,
like you're screwed.
Yeah.
I'm having like a hand injuries,
like the,
probably the worst injury you could have.
I mean,
we,
we eat with these hands,
you know,
this is our,
this is how we survive,
you know?
And when you have an ng like that,
there's going to be fighting with the other.
Do you remember when you arrive?
Faber fought Mike Brown and broke both hands and just start throwing elbows and
slapping though.
It just didn't give in for a second.
Yeah.
It's all tough.
That motherfucker is two broken hands.
Trying to find a way to win.
Yeah.
It's measurable.
That's a,
yeah,
it was a title fight too.
Yup.
You do amazing things for tidal flat.
No,
but I,
I want,
I want it to bring in Joe,
if you allow me,
I'm a cook because I'm honored man.
And I think,
uh,
I think,
I brought the men jokes.
I want to kind of share,
uh,
you know,
kind of like the new age stuff,
like something that's just taken over the top.
So cat,
Kat,
Kevin,
if you can hear me,
come on.
Can't,
there's a bit long delay.
There's like a 32nd delay.
You can go grab him.
Okay,
I'll grab him.
Yeah,
go grab him captain.
He's going to come back with a new layer.
So to come back with a cape.
He's going to come back naked.
We don't have another microphone though,
unfortunately.
So he's going to have to take your spot because there's not another microphone.
Do you think of Captain America?
Man,
we use a fourth microphone.
We actually have to set it up and it's not up right now.
And so what do you think of Captain America?
He's hilarious at that.
That we got to them.
Oh,
you know how you are with uh,
um,
with addy.
That's Kinda how,
how he a high with them,
you know,
that's it.
It's that,
is that,
no,
it's that certain relationship.
Yep.
Hey man,
that helps.
How are you sir?
Well,
good.
How you doing Joe?
Shop.
Tell everybody who you are.
I mean,
I'm Kevin Long.
Gloria.
I am the chief science officer for Neuro Force One and then I'm a neuro
physiologist as well.
So keep this about like a fist from your face.
Okay.
So um,
tell us what your role was in camp and what you did to,
to help him get ready.
Cool.
Yeah,
so a neuro force one is a neuroscience based training company and a medical
grade diagnostic testing company as well.
Where are you guys were at a Scottsdale,
Arizona.
So what we really focus on,
which a lot of companies aren't talking about is the role of the gut and the
mind in conjunction with your physical training.
So essentially what we do is we start off with a really comprehensive baseline
assessment.
We want to run them through everything.
So the traditional functional threshold powers,
autonomic nervous system,
DC brain potentials.
And really what you want to do is you want to put somebody on a,
on a normal curve,
what does a DC brain potential DC brain potentials that you want to be like
Daniel Cormier,
Yay we DC bring,
I want to be a little bit like DC but uh,
basically it's uh,
an objective measurement of your central nervous system.
So you can actually,
your central nervous system is basically the data aggregator if you will.
So it has to take information from your metabolic systems,
your autonomics kind of coordinate things like neuromuscular and I met metabolic
efficiency.
That's kind of the,
the data center if you will.
So this is a measurement of a potential basically how much energy you have in
the,
in the central nervous system to go coordinate neuro muscular and metabolic
efficiencies,
which is really what we focus on.
So as soon as this on like a chart or are you getting like is there a number of
reading that you're getting?
Like what is it that
correct specifically for dcs,
it's going to be in millivolts and then you just compare that to normative
ranges.
But most importantly,
what it is,
is trending data over time.
This is an assessment that we would do on Henry every single morning.
It's a home test kit.
We really believe in just collecting as much data as possible and trending data.
That way when you see a change essentially get predictability in terms of now
today's a no go day because central nervous system is diminished.
We're just going to be going through the motions.
We're not going to make physiological adaptations.
Uh,
and your inflammation is really high.
No go because we're not going to go risk injury when we can't make adaptations.
So this is a measurement we would do every single morning where we can look at
autonomic nervous system,
which is basically things like recovery,
sympathetic,
parasympathetic balance,
DC brain potentials and metabolic systems.
What is,
what is measuring all these things?
Is there a device?
Is it a yeah.
Yeah.
This is a pretty amazing device.
We actually got it from the UFC performance institute,
you know,
shout out to those guys,
Clint Bobo and Roman over there.
Um,
set us up with this technology to basically a chest strap that does heart rate
variability.
So time and frequency domain analysis.
And then it does DC brain potential.
So they'll stick your right here on your forehead,
uh,
basically four minutes.
You just kind of relax and we collect pretty amazing data and it breaks it down
into four different categories.
What's called windows of trainability.
So it says today we should focus on strength and power or skill acquisition
based on metabolic readiness,
autonomic readiness in DC brain potentials.
So what is our body prime to go do today?
Cause if you're not primed,
your nervous system doesn't have the energy just going to be going through the
motions.
So you were sort of there to dictate when it's going to be a hard day,
when it's going to be an easy day.
Correct.
Yeah.
And that's something as you,
I'm sure you guys know in wrestling it's,
it's always hard always.
Let's go.
Um,
so this was a,
a little bit of an issue in the camp at the very beginning.
If you could imagine Henry wakes up,
it's a sparring day or maybe even supposed to do two a days.
He wakes up feeling really good and nervous system is out of whack.
It's like,
sorry man,
I know you feel good but you're not,
you know?
Yeah.
So we would go or no go that day.
And you know,
as you could see,
it all worked out in the long run.
Oh fantastic.
What was that weird for you to feel good and then do we told you got to chill
out.
Yeah.
And it was a,
it almost takes a while to kind of adapt.
But I started as I started recognizing like my body change in how I felt
inspiring or how they were and how Kinda I,
I just felt recovered.
I was like,
God,
this is,
this is crazy.
Like I didn't run at all this whole camp.
So do you get a baseline off of this,
Eric?
You got to stop moving around.
You're freaking me out.
I was doing the hand signals back there,
translating for the deaf people.
So what do you do a baseline on this before you get started and then you as
before camp gets started and then when camp starts ramping up,
then
you start measuring all the various details,
correct?
Yeah,
so we do a comprehensive baseline assessment,
including the Omegawave as well as,
you know,
six or eight hours of other testing,
everything that you could think of under the sun.
And we put together a basically columns of this is what your sub optimal at,
this is what your average at,
this is what you're really damn good at.
So basically what we want to do is explore your functional strengths.
It's what you're good at.
But then we also want to focus on your functional deficiencies.
In a sport like MMA,
we also sometimes have the advantage of looking at your opponent and making
certain assumptions in terms of their weaknesses,
their strengths going against somebody like Dj,
you don't,
you don't really have that advantage.
So we really needed to focus on is what Henry is really good at.
His ground game.
You look,
you know,
we're doing nervous system assessments while he's on the ground.
His sparring partners or stresses sins are going like crazy.
He's calming down cause this guy likes to be on the floor rolling around.
So we pinpoint these little strategic dif dif,
a strengths and deficiencies and then we target all of us a nutrition
supplementation.
A big thing that we focus on is nutrient timing.
Something that's not really talked about as well when you're talking about gut
health and you know,
recovery,
managing the hormones associated with exercise,
you gotta be getting in the right nutrients in your,
your energy,
Anabolic and growth phases.
So for nutrient timing,
you talking about like when you're actually eating and what you're eating.
So you're planning that out as well.
100% yes.
So we put together a nutrition program and because training varies every morning
we're deciding what we're going to do for the day.
It's completely dynamic.
It's,
we're kind of reinventing the game of periodization and programming because you
can't give somebody an eight week plan.
You have to check every single day.
This is how you stay very dynamic and you avoid plateaus and just the issues,
you know,
it's always going to lead to suboptimal performance if you're programming out.
So every day we adjust,
you know,
we're doing this intensity of training.
We did a vo two Max assessment so we know exactly how much glycogen you're
burning at various levels of intensity.
We do heart rate tracking during your training.
All right,
this is exactly what you have to replace following.
So I'm standing on the sidelines,
you know,
after every practice mixing up custom supplements for him as well.
So this is something,
what kind of stuff?
Um,
you know,
we have our own supplement line right now.
I'm frankly not because the world needed another supplement line.
It's not really what our goal was.
Um,
in,
in sports like this,
you have to be so careful what you're putting in these guys body.
Uh,
so we just went the route of going GMP certified water.
You sought approved on everything we do.
Um,
eventually we want to,
you know,
try and work with the bad ass company cause we're not,
we don't want to be in the supplement game.
For us it was just quality control.
Um,
so,
uh,
being a nervous system based company,
obviously we're doing things like Omega three Dhas Bcas,
you know,
to maintain,
put on a little bit of muscle.
Um,
we do a lot of big one I believe in this is the generation you can,
the SuperStarch very good without a big glycaemic in a big insulin response,
but very good at replenishing your glycogen stores following to minimize
cortisol and inflammatory responses and things like that.
So,
um,
everyday it's a little bit different.
But uh,
yeah,
we ended up going with our own line and one of the biggest things that we didn't
ever really talk about in the fight as well is the,
the role that gut health place.
So that's something Henry does year round regardless of when we're fighting is
take our line,
which is called freedom cleansers store.
And this is world renown,
um,
you know,
utilize by university researchers all around the world right now.
And basically it's all just about restoring good gut bacteria,
prebiotics,
probiotics and lymphatic cleansing.
And this is going to be something,
um,
that really played a big role in his weight cut as well.
It's kind of a missing link that athletes aren't talking about,
but good gut health is going to help with serotonin production.
So recovery,
relaxation,
mood,
you know,
production of brain derived neurotrophic factor.
So our nervous system can make these adaptations and learn new skills and things
along these lines.
So this is something,
you know,
in my opinion,
a big reason why,
uh,
you know,
he had the issue with Dj the first time around.
Henry Henry will tell the story like he had gut inflammation so bad that people
would say good luck before the fight.
Tap His gut and,
and that hurt him.
You know,
that's not normal.
That all goes back to the issues associated with weight cutting as we were
talking about a little bit.
But uh,
getting that gut health right,
no inflammation in the,
and that goes a long way.
Now,
how long have you guys been in business for a,
we've only been in business for about eight months.
We're still very new.
Um,
been working with Henry A.
Little bit longer than that.
Um,
but yeah,
this company is just getting off the ground.
We,
we kind of rebranded a few months ago,
just opened our first facility as well out in Scottsdale.
What is your background in?
Um,
I'm a,
I'm a physiologist.
I,
we opened the first mobile medical grade diagnostic testing company in Arizona.
So basically I would have these diagnostics and largely it was trying to,
trying to fix the healthcare system a little bit,
you know,
uh,
we,
we want individualized solutions.
We want datadriven outcomes,
right?
You want quantifiable progress.
So people want to feel good about what they're doing,
but maybe a doctor can't afford a this big ass metabolic cart or they don't know
how to use it.
So what I did is I purchased this equipment,
hire technicians,
and we would bring it mobile technology's getting smaller,
more mobile.
So this was my idea of,
of how I would go make my little dent in the healthcare system.
Um,
you know,
there were issues with scalability in terms of finding good technicians,
but the goal is just to go out there and provide data driven solutions,
right?
We live in a world of,
of subjectivity,
guesswork,
a very punishment oriented fitness system where it sucks the start working out
you,
you typically gain weight if you're doing the right stuff cause you're getting
hydrated,
you go get injured.
You know,
the goal is to redefine how we assess people so that we can find these little,
little tweaks for positive reinforcement.
And that's a,
it goes a long way with healthcare as well as fitness.
So you guys mostly working with civilians,
are you working with pro athletes?
Oh,
right now we're in the research and development phase so we're really only
working with guys like a Henry,
Victoria,
Anthony.
I've a very bad ass dresser we're working with right now as well.
Um,
just some amazing people.
Uh,
largely for research and development.
We,
we trade them the training for the data.
You know,
you guys get together.
Uh,
we've been working with Henry about a year.
He,
I knew,
he knew our CEO,
Karima mean a great guy.
We've kind of all circle around a Korean.
He brought us all together.
Um,
but uh,
you know,
he came in probably about eight months ago for a little bit before the first
camp and we met talked and no,
Henry was straight up.
He's like,
man you,
you know your stuff but you don't know MMA.
So I took that,
you know,
personally we,
spent a lot of time together.
I had to learn the sport.
I'm a physiologist,
not an MMA physiologist.
So we really took the time to get to know each other,
you know,
hang out a lot.
Now I got to go to his house and wake them up every day for eight weeks.
So that was,
you got to know each other pretty well.
I do as meals trips and stuff much.
Yeah,
that's a fantastic
stick combination though.
A guy like you who knows so much about the body and recovery and a real super
high level Olympic gold medalist athlete.
I mean,
when you get that combination mean that is,
that's really a dream for God to like you and for a guy like you,
like for both of you guys to come together like this.
And I understand why you wanted to bring him on.
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
uh,
you know,
I understand half of,
if you understand half of it.
Yeah,
yeah.
The DC mine thing,
that Shit's important.
But no,
I mean,
I do feel honored and blessed to be able to work with somebody like Henry.
He's the hardest working guy out there.
And,
and of course the hard work goes a long ways,
but man,
this guy's a genetic freak as well.
I found the ability to test the Olympic athletes,
many other sports as well.
This guy makes adaptations faster than anybody.
He came off of,
you know,
12 weeks,
16 weeks maybe of not training vo two two's already in the high sixties
functional threshold power is that would go compete with the,
you know,
worldclass ironmen that I'm training and things as well.
And then,
I mean,
we,
we did some amazing stuff.
If you looked at the body composition changes that we did in seven weeks,
it wasn't even a full eight week camp.
Um,
he put on 4.2 pounds of skeletal muscle mass,
like good mass,
which as a physiologist I would call bullshit on if I didn't see it with my own
two eyes.
That's pretty incredible.
Yeah.
Incredible.
And Henry will tell you,
he may be picked up weights like three or four times.
We don't really do traditional strength training because you know,
a lot of people just,
it's called vector based training.
So a lot of people do things like squats and dead lifts.
This is an axial plane,
like we don't live in this up and down plain.
So we break it down by vector,
what angles,
what does he need to exert and absorb force and very effectively and very really
does that come down to actually utilizing weights.
We do things like positional isom metrics and east centric training and things
along these lines.
Number one,
they integrate with the nervous system very effectively.
Symmetrics yeah,
positional isometric like planks.
I mean that's,
that's kind of a low level of it.
Yeah.
Largely what you would want to do is like a biomechanical assessment,
look at overactive and underactive muscles,
and then you put them in very specific positions and you leverage what's called
recip reciprocal inhibition.
So basically,
and then the most basic term,
like when I'm flexing my Bicep,
my tricep is relaxing.
So you'd hold certain positions that you want to turn on certain muscles and
kind of turn off other ones.
It's kind of a high level of of PNF stretching,
proprioceptive neuromuscular facilitation.
So this is what would be done in like a PT office.
So w in like for wrestling,
like what kind of exercises would you do that would incorporate those methods?
I mean wrestling is you know,
largely a torsional sports.
So when it comes to wrestling we do things like,
like Kaiser,
like pneumatic compressions and things like that.
So instead of weights we use air pressure.
Basically.
It's very smooth,
very low risk of injury.
And they live in this arm,
this torsional plane.
So you do a lot of transverse plane and we do a lot of velocity based training
as well.
Actually really interesting.
A study that was published recently.
A,
they had a lot of guys working on it for a full year.
Some only did velocity,
never actually picked up a weight.
The other ones that traditional strength training,
the people who did velocity based training now,
no actual weight training got stronger with less muscular hypertrophy.
I mean they didn't get as big but they were stronger at the end of the day.
So when you look at something like wrestling and MMA where you got to make a low
weight but you want to be shown as possible,
you know,
velocity based training is kind of the way of the future.
So this is kind of our general gym concept that we're building right now is,
is you know,
the gym of the future may not need weights.
You know,
we're going to be next door to these crossfit gyms where they're throwing all
these weights over their head,
getting injured or next door empty gym and people are getting stronger.
That's,
that's kind of the,
the gym of the future,
the way we see it.
How would you divine velocity based training.
Um,
so basically what you want to do is it's kind of like the new one rep Max.
We all know one rep Max is aren't the safest thing to perform,
right?
So you would,
uh,
there's different assessments.
Actually what I'm wearing here on my wrist right now,
this is the wearable tech of the future.
This is something we're testing right now.
This does velocity.
So I could send in any position,
I could do a push press or I could do a punch.
This is going to measure my velocity.
Your Max Velocity at no weight would be your one rep Max velocity basically.
And then you're going in,
you're doing your training.
So Max velocity,
every single rep,
when you hit 20% dampening,
so see I was at 10 meters per second.
As soon as I hit eight meters or eight meters per second,
I stop.
So this is kind of what they call fatigue.
So you stopped that.
So instead of doing,
you know,
you're going to do eight reps,
you do as many reps as you can until you reach a certain dampening of velocity.
And what are you doing them with?
Largely things like the Kaiser,
the functional trainer,
if you're familiar with that blasting band work.
Yeah.
Things like that.
I mean very rarely will throw like,
you know,
Indian clubs and things like that in there as well.
So it all depends on the sport and what we're focusing on that day.
You know,
metabolic readiness,
things along those lines.
But it's all just about training in the right vectors and being able to not only
put out force but absorb force as well,
which nobody really talks about.
And if you look at largely other professional sports,
all these injuries are happening in the deceleration phase.
So when people are trying to slow down,
this is absorbing force.
This is kind of similar through some of the pieces that just aren't trained in
MMA as well has got to be able to absorb force just like you put it out.
Now when you met this risk thing that you're wearing,
it measures velocity.
So how's it doing that?
Um,
so basically I have one here and then I have one on my shoe as well.
So it can do it by using two sensors that can measure relative velocity.
So it's reading one relative to the other.
This is also doing everything that a bad ass traditional wearable would do as
well.
So it's doing my heart rate,
heart rate variability,
which is actually clinical grade.
Everything we do has got to be clinical grade cause what's the point of
collecting data if it's shit right.
Um,
and then it does pulse oximetry.
So I'm looking at my oxygen saturation.
The next version is going to be able to do hydration,
all kinds of bad stuff.
What's really cool about it as well as it can measure form any exercise that
you're doing.
We can compare you essentially to an ideal form.
And because we have to,
you don't even have to tell it.
You're doing a power clean,
it can read your motions and things like that.
And it gives you like a consistency number as well.
So we,
one thing we really talk about is is not building muscle on top of dysfunction.
We have to get your biomechanical patterns right first and then we start putting
muscle on.
If you just put muscle on top of dysfunction,
you're facili facilitating further dysfunction.
Would you have to wear one of those on each hand?
Um,
I mean I'd say the fee,
ideally for someone like a fighter,
you obviously you're thrown with both hands.
Um,
I think it would be ideal.
it's,
it's really difficult at time sync multiple devices to be on the same timeline.
So that's something we're working with this company,
an amazing company actually out of here at to La to develop this thing right
now.
So that I would say that'd be the goal.
It's,
it's not something that's going to be applicable to the average guy though as
well.
This,
we're trying to bring this type of training to everybody.
Would it be possible instead of time sinking it,
you have a left and a right computer,
like two different computers that are reading data both on one off the left,
one off the rights.
So you don't have to coordinate them.
You just look at the various data.
I mean,
at the end of the day,
you still would have to sync them,
you know?
So the thing there,
you'd be collecting it in two different sets of hardware.
You'd want an API connectivity,
put it up in the cloud,
and then you'd still at the end of the day have to find the same time axis.
So it,
it sounds simpler than it really would be.
That's why this is the only wearable in the world right now that has even one in
the foot.
And so this also allows you to track your gate while you're running and things
as well.
But the more devices the more complex in,
in,
you know,
that's something I think would be great but maybe not applicable to everybody.
Is it going to be able to track martial arts moves?
Like will it be able to track a double leg take down or a roundhouse kick or
anything like that?
Right now you can program it to do anything.
Um,
you put it into a kind of like a learning mode on the,
on your app,
you do a few motions,
you name it,
and then it can,
can basically compare you to yourself in that mode.
So you can try and do perfect form and measure your form relative to yourself.
But if you have shitty form,
you're comparing yourself to shitty for.
Exactly.
So it doesn't know any better.
So what we're doing right now,
um,
which,
which will be a little bit of a lengthy process is defining a library of perfect
form for everything that you could think of.
And then this,
you know,
this is going to a lock telehealth and tell the training when you have something
like that.
We can do remote programming and,
and have been,
you know,
be monitoring people's neuromuscular function,
their biomechanics completely remotely.
So that's,
that's really what we're going towards.
Wow.
This is fascinating stuff man.
You know,
there's always been a several aspects to getting a fighter ready for camp.
There's always been their skillset,
what they're good at,
um,
specific training for that one individual opponent of they're going to face and
then all the strength and conditioning and you know,
it's usually thought of as,
you know,
weights and sprints and pliers and on all these different things.
But I feel like this is probably the next step.
The next step,
measuring all of your,
all these variables that you're talking about and seeing how your body is at any
given time so that you're not just guessing whether you're piquing your
scientifically peaking.
Exactly man.
I mean there's,
there's just no room for guesswork and subjectivity,
you know,
at this level and in technology doesn't,
there's no need for it anymore.
So we're just trying to let people know shit like this is available,
right?
So we're developing it and then the end goal is just to make it extremely user
friendly,
right?
So you're doing your,
your velocity based training and it says stop and then you rest and we're using
your heart rate variability to tell you when to go again.
So like,
you know,
it's easy to stop and go for your,
your periodization and things like that so that the technology's here now making
it,
you know,
actionable recommendations for the individual that can understand is,
is kind of what we're moving towards.
This is awesome stuff,
man.
Thank you.
Yeah,
we're really passionate about what we're doing.
You've only been around for such a short amount of time to,
and yet you already have a world champion.
Oh,
I know man.
I mean I feel,
you know,
there's times where you feel like you didn't deserve the opportunity because
I'm,
I'm new to the field,
you know,
we obviously work our asses off and everything,
but the,
for Henry to put the faith into us,
you know,
this was a world champion camp.
We're a company.
Honestly,
we're not even open yet.
This is probably one of the best acceleration for a company that's never seen
the light of day ever.
Um,
you know,
we also run a few other sports as well,
but yeah,
for him to give us this opportunity and you know,
we felt like we owed them something so we worked extra hard,
essentially put our entire company on hold for eight weeks to go help him out.
And you know,
it's paying dividends.
Obviously we're here right now.
Now are you guys going to be open to the general public?
Say the the,
the average girl or guy who does say Jujitsu tournaments and wants to get in the
best shape of their life is are you going to have products for them and a
service where they can sign up for something like that.
Certainly right now we are already open in terms of of diagnostic testing.
So you can come in based on your sport,
your goal,
whatever it may be.
We have customized diagnostic packages cause some assessments just aren't
applicable to some people.
So we customize your assessment.
We basically tell you what you're good at,
what you're bad at.
Then if you want to,
you know,
develop a program that's a little bit of an upcharge to the real goal there is
to be able to do completely remote training completely in house training and
then any level of hybrid training as well.
So right now you know what the world needs is the diagnostic testing the data.
We're already ready to do that.
What we're building now is the processes of being able to use data,
put it into recommendations and then scale that.
It's hard to teach somebody,
you know,
everything that I do.
So we're building the,
you know,
the,
the software's to essentially replicate ourselves.
Like my,
my buddy in the other room,
Andre Hicks,
one of the best strength and conditioning coaches in the world.
These guys will attest to it.
Um,
you,
you can't teach people what he knows.
So we have to like code this into a software a lot of if then type stuff and
then this is a able to be scalable to everybody.
We want to provide this training,
uh,
to,
to people now the average Joe trying to lose weight,
you know,
the weekend warrior,
the Jujitsu,
everything.
Then we want to be able to provide this to everybody.
Everybody deserves this type of training.
That's minimal risk of injury,
high yield,
return efficient.
That's what everyone's looking for and that's,
that's why the people are getting fatter.
There's,
there's no good positive reinforcement out there and there's no clear roadmap
how to get to where you want to be.
You know,
we,
we put together like,
you know,
comparing it to Google maps,
everybody knows their end.
They know where they want to be,
but it can't tell you where you're at unless you know exactly where you're
starting from.
You have to do this baseline assessment and they'll sometimes,
it sucks to really understand how fat your,
you know,
your body fat percentage and your metabolic,
and you're at risk of,
you know,
your insulin resistance and things like that.
But you have to figure out where you're starting from,
where you want to be.
And that's how we develop a roadmap.
So getting people,
you know,
and,
and we believe this is,
this is the way of kind of making our way into the healthcare system as well.
That's our end goal as a company to be able to provide,
you know,
integrative fitness is what we're calling it.
Taking little pieces from all the different methodologies of a fitness,
like,
you know,
we,
we bring meditation and Yoga into our practice as well.
So little pieces of just about everything and be able to provide this to
everybody that that's what we're doing.
So in the future,
when you guys are open,
you're,
you're not totally open to the general public yet,
right?
Correct.
Yeah,
about six or eight months.
Would someone have to come to you for the first initial assessments and then
possibly be able to do the consulting either online or you know,
through,
through the application?
I mean,
there's totally different degrees.
We have a hundred percent remote kits right now.
There's bad ass stuff you can do on your iPad,
like biomechanical assessments that can find your joints and things like that.
We can send this to you.
There's a lot of things that we want to be able to do.
A hundred percent remote for the most complex assessment.
You got to come in,
you got to do a vo two Max assessment.
We can't send you a metabolic cart and shit obviously.
So the goal is to get people to just come into the facility and then do remote
programming from there.
And this is uh,
you know,
our,
our concept is to put these diagnostic centers and possibly the attached
training centers as well and just start providing these everywhere.
Because,
frankly,
if we just went,
you know,
the,
the diagnostic Jim of the future route,
it could be five,
600 square feet low,
you know,
low overhead facilities that are just really efficient,
just putting people out,
collecting data left and right.
That's amazing,
man.
Yeah.
Well,
what does it been like for you to make this gigantic change and to basically be
like Ivan Drago?
Yeah,
pretty much.
That's,
that's,
that's pretty much how,
it's kind of how it's kind of been like we took in that,
uh,
the Ivan Drago approach probably more than the rocky approach,
which I think,
I think Russia is kind of tend to use science a little bit more than their
training.
So to me,
at first it was almost like,
man,
I'm,
I'm going all in on this,
especially this cap against Demetrius.
I'm like,
God,
I'm,
I'm going all in man.
Like,
I'm going to have faith in the science of why I got 100%.
I'm gonna do everything according to even,
you know,
even if even if I don't want to.
And that's,
and I think he just,
as I started seeing my body change,
I started seeing like the coaches kind of adapt with like,
okay,
mass science is in the center of this whole cat.
And I saw the change though.
And I've never felt so recovered the night that I fought Demetrius Johnson,
I've never felt so good.
And I'm 31 years old and I've been cutting weight since I've,
since I've been a kid.
So you felt a big difference through the entire camp doing this kind of method
through the entire camp.
People would trip out.
It'd be like,
people were like,
no,
you're committed.
You're,
that's suicide.
Do you,
how come you're not doing this?
How come you're not doing that?
And a,
you would have to look at it and saying,
how can we not doing like what specifically?
Oh No,
just a,
just a more work,
more,
more pad work,
more uh,
more sparring rounds,
like things of that man,
I'd like to kind of like the gladiator stuff.
They're like,
no,
it's,
it's an a goal according to my heart rate.
It's going to,
it's going to go according to what?
Well,
my windows,
what my train of my windows of opportunity of training are.
You know what kind of Mumbo jumbo they're like,
yeah.
Like nobody knows.
Like the day that I wake up,
the day that I train,
like nobody knows what's going on until,
until,
until the data's got in the hands of Kevin and Neuro Force One and then they,
okay,
they,
they determine this is how many rounds,
this is how we're going to kind of pick you for your fight.
If you could imagine standing on the sideline when he's like sparring and rounds
and stuff and more slow down periods here,
like coaches,
like you can't do that.
This is fighting.
You can't try and control your heart rate while training and now this is
training for fighting.
Right.
You know,
so we're,
we're telling constantly telling him to train less slow himself down.
You know,
there was a little bit of clashing there at the beginning and then they started
to see the body composition come around and started to feel his power and,
and everyone kind of bought into the process.
But it takes a while.
We're not,
we're,
we're redefining it and we understand that there's gonna be some pushback.
This is such a universal concept when it comes to strength and conditioning
coaches,
it's being discussed over and over again nowadays is that people are doing too
much,
they're doing too much and your body's just doesn't have a chance to recover.
And even though you're getting in better shape,
ultimately you're not getting in as good a shape as you could have gotten if you
did less,
which is so counter intuitive for most people.
Yeah.
And that's Kinda how it,
that's,
that's Kinda how I used to train so hard,
but I used to get hurt.
I'm a nice to have back spasms kicking.
Like that's how hard I would train.
Like,
oh my back would literally go out just kicking.
I'll throw one kick and they had to pull me off the gym in a stretcher,
you know,
and I had those problems because I had just,
I really,
I didn't you almost train according to you how,
how you know what the,
how the schedule is rather than,
okay,
this is this,
this is the approach today because this is this,
this is how your stress levels are like relaxed too.
And then,
and then at times you're going to go hard and it's,
it'll spike you at target.
It's,
it's,
it's crazy.
Well that's the
crazy contrast,
right?
As between this championship mentality that just wants to do more than anybody.
Push harder train while everybody else is asleep.
Put your body through more than anybody else is willing to do because that's
what makes a champion and then someone like you comes along goes,
no,
that's what more,
that's what fucks you up.
You need to slow down.
You do last less rounds.
Move slower.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean that was one of the biggest things I told them.
If you're not sleeping eight to 10 hours a night,
when you're putting your body through something like that,
you're doing your body and injustice and you're not going to make adaptations
when we're out there training or breaking our body down.
It needs this repair.
We need,
you know,
activate our glymphatic system,
our brains waste removal system as well.
So we can go learn some new things the next day as well.
So if you're not sleeping,
you're sub optimal just like you're not properly hydrated and things as well.
This is,
this is all comes down to the cellular level,
you know,
nervous system based approach.
Now are you taking Melatonin or anything to ensure that you go to sleep at a
specific time?
Do you time your sleep sky schedule?
Like how are you organizing that?
Yeah,
I think,
and that's another thing,
even at times,
uh,
according to when I would go to sleep.
Cause at that time do you know how you train late and sometimes you come back
and it just takes you a while to go to sleep.
Yeah.
So even then it would,
it would it be like,
all right,
when,
when Henry's ready to wake up,
when it,
obviously if I don't hit my alarm and I snooze it,
I'm more lucky they can allow me to sleep an extra two hours,
which is important.
Yeah.
So it's like the vibe,
it's kind of like we'll,
Floyd does flow will be like,
hey,
we'll wake everybody up at three in the morning,
but there's no scientific to what flow is doing.
Like to us it's like,
hey dude,
let's we have to pick today.
So
if there is science behind it and he just doesn't talk about it,
you know,
it was Floyd like you don't know.
Yeah,
I like to think so.
Yeah.
Like when he drinks a Pepsi after a workout,
it was like a wonder there's no science that I told him to do that,
to replenish his body with a ton of sugar and high glycemic carbs right after.
That's the only time it's really good.
That little 45 window of insulin sensitivity.
So I do believe that one technology,
we,
uh,
what while we're on the sleep thing,
one that we were utilizing for Henry,
um,
just little light microcurrent here to your temporal lobes and it's proven to
increase serotonin and Melatonin and decreased cortisol.
So we're like manipulating biochemicals and it's a very natural way of making
you feel drowsy.
What time do you do that up?
We would do that immediately following every rigorous training session to kind
of like negate inflammatory responses and things like that.
And I'll get you back into that anabolic phase as quickly as possible.
And then ideally right before bed,
every single night.
Did you feel like a science project?
Well,
this shit was going on.
Did I did actually they did a presentation on me and,
and Russia with Roman,
with the,
with the scientists at the habit,
they use p I like,
they tracked everything according to the Omegawave,
the device that we're using.
And he was able to kind of show it was I,
hey look,
my system might,
you know,
this system does work.
You know,
it's just like people were kind of just tripping out.
So I was,
I went out there,
did the whole presentation with a at Moscow and the,
everybody was just kind of just like,
everybody was kind of like,
wow,
amazing.
Someone works kind of scratching their head and a little like,
damn,
that's that.
That's cool.
You're able to kind of see how I peaked for this fight and how I was able to
kind of survive fibroids.
The Russians
really been pioneering this type of training for quite a while.
Specifically the,
the type of training like that Pavel tot saline uses,
like where you're using way less energy,
you're working out way less,
but you're getting better results from it.
Like there's,
there's a lot of thought processes that have been leaning in this direction from
a,
like a lot of really high level top coaches for quite a while now.
Yeah.
No,
and it's cool to see it cause I come from a traditional sport where you put your
head down and you'd go,
that's how fast rustling and more tight.
I think they're very,
uh,
they're very alike in that sense.
I could,
they're very traditional.
Like the harder you go,
the more you push through injury,
the,
you know,
the better you will become.
Yeah.
I also think that there's something to be said for that though in terms of
mental strength because one of the things that wrestlers have that is,
it's not just that they have a great skill and being able to manipulate bodies,
but they also have mental toughness.
That's at a level that I don't think you get from any other sport.
I mean I think there's a lot of pro athletes,
even tennis players that are just mentally tough.
They're just tough so people just know how to win.
They know how to push themselves,
but I feel like wrestlers are on another level cause they're always tired.
They're always overtrained,
they're always dehydrated and they're always working out with a bunch of fucking
savages.
They're all the same way and everybody takes pleasure in being miserable.
There's something to that that like you see it,
man,
I've seen thousands of fights.
You see there's something about wrestlers they have just like an extra gear,
like a high level wrestler in particular has an extra gear that a lot of other
fighters just never developed.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's almost like I tell people wrestling's not,
it's almost like not a sport man.
It's like a culture.
Yes.
It's like you're just,
you're,
you're in the culture of rustling and once you have that,
it's almost,
there's an honor to it.
There's a warrior to it and like,
and it's,
it's,
it,
I was just at the world championship,
Joe and I can tell you,
man,
the best athletes in the world,
I was just in Budapest,
Hungary and I saw Kyle Snyder and all these guys compete.
And I'm just like,
man,
these are the most,
these are the best athletes in the world.
This is the hardest shit a human being could ever do.
If you're to see the finesse and the strength and the power and what's involved
in becoming a world champion of watching these guys go through this freaking
tucks.
Just a tough,
the toughest tournament in the world.
And it's a,
I think,
I think what we do in a minute is fun compared to a competitor wrestling.
I really do like that stuff is like,
man that stuff is hard with these guys go through win a tournament.
Like it's the weight cuts,
the,
you know,
they don't get paid a lot of money.
Like these dudes are literally Alpha,
the Gloria all each and every one of them.
It's all glory.
There's no financial reward at all.
That's what's fascinating about it.
But it's just interesting to me that I think you kind of need both in some weird
way.
Your mind needs to develop this,
this layer of toughness that wrestlers have and then I think once you've
developed that then maybe I think your approach Kevin is,
is like applicable.
But I think that until an athlete has that indomitable spirit until they have
that sort of that iron will that a wrestler possesses,
it's theirs to make a champion.
I think you need many,
many things,
but I,
I don't think you can ever discount that ability to work through discomfort the
way wrestlers have.
I just don't think it's wise as a professional athlete at a championship level
to compete compromised.
Oh,
agreed.
Yeah.
You know,
there,
there's the intangibles,
the stuff that you just can't teach,
you can't quantify,
you know?
So what we do our best to quantify as much as we can,
but yeah,
I mean I completely agree.
There's,
you got to put in the time and the work to learn the skill at some point and
then once you know it,
it's autonomic.
The skills master,
that's when you can kind of kick it back into order method.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna agree with you Joe.
I think I'm going to agree with you.
And I think the reason why this works for pretty much every MMA fighters because
we've all been through hell.
Yeah.
Like an order for you to see an end believe in science is you have to go through
how to understand like,
hey man,
the hard way probably isn't the best way.
But when you were talking about your,
your,
the feeling that you had in not wanting to ever feel the pain of losing again,
that feeling that you had when your ankle is going out and that they'd be like,
fuck this.
No,
no,
I'm not doing this.
I'm going to find a way out of this.
Like you almost have to experience lows in order to have that.
And I,
I feel like one of the things about wrestling that makes it a sport that creates
so many fucking savages is because you go through so much shit,
so much hardship,
so,
so much difficulty that you know,
if you had science based wrestling programs the way you're doing a science based
camp and you went in and you know,
said everybody,
you got to slow down,
slow down.
You know like you,
you're going too hard,
slow down,
can't run up hills today.
You know,
your,
your DC brain waves or a wrestling coach would be like,
shut the fuck up and sit to,
who is this asshole give Dan Gable brought you in a camp and you guys are
running around doing all this stuff.
He'd be like,
what?
Like,
what are you saying?
Like this is how we make champions.
Yeah.
But like I said,
I think you hit the nail on the head.
I think it's for,
to me,
the way I would see it as like,
you have to kind of go through how a,
that understanding because you had to go through that callus through that burn.
But I feel like,
especially in MMA,
a lot of athletes or even athletes just in general,
they,
everybody buses or butts on what's,
if you're an elite athlete,
like you'll,
you'll always train,
maybe not the smartest way.
Yeah.
You know,
like it's,
uh,
yeah,
I guess you could add more to,
to your training or,
or,
or take away less if there's a,
but there's a fine line to it.
Do you have the fine line is what's fascinating to me?
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
like one of the things that I love about MMA is that it's so broad.
There are so many skills that the approach to success is different with every
individual.
And you have to find what that approach is like the approach to you for your,
for you,
for you to achieve success is going to be different than the approach for a
different athlete.
It doesn't,
it doesn't have the same skills that you have,
but like Anderson Silva,
perfect example,
he's not a wrestler.
It's going to have a different,
different approach.
This,
there's going to be different things that they work on and training,
there's going to be a different mindset.
It's going to a different way of preparing.
Right,
right.
And,
and,
and it's all according to everybody according like not,
it's,
I think a lot of things are cookie cutter.
Like looking at it the way now,
it's like a lot of things have have stayed even in wrestling,
like just over tradition,
you know,
like bridging,
like every time I see you,
but bridge and the way they stretched and they're gonna be like,
do that shit so bad for you.
And then that'd be doing like these like springs on their head.
I'm just like,
Kevin,
how bad,
how bad is bridging for you?
Uh,
I mean,
I,
I wouldn't recommend it.
I mean,
uh,
it,
but Mike Tyson always looked bad ass and he's doing it.
But I was going to say it looks pretty bad ass.
I mean,
teacher,
have you ever
thrown with the iron neck with the iron neck?
We don't know about that.
Oh,
I got one.
gotta try this and sell some of your videos.
That's definitely one of the missing links.
Why a lot of these wrestlers get hurt.
Then,
you know,
neck and stability,
the postural issues that had come associated with it as well as guys need to
strengthen their necks.
It's a halo.
You put it on,
you pump it up like a Reebok pump.
Remember the Reebok pump,
you pump this sucker up so it tightens up on your head.
You put a chin strap on,
it's got a bungee cable on that's set to 50 pounds back up.
And then there's resistance on the halo so it spins the resist.
The Halo has like you could tighten up our clamp down or loosen up the
resistance and you do these exercises.
Like
he goes sideways.
You do like,
like,
like loops back and forth.
It's,
it's fucking bad ass.
That's crazy.
I'm excited man.
I got to,
yeah,
you got to trust that why sign that waiver is that
you signed a waiver because we got to get ahold of some of that weed while
you're running through walls and all the
in the float tank if you want to try the food because the waivers for two,
I don't want you to lose your mind.
Yeah.
The sensory immersion that let's float tanks,
they're pretty bad ass.
We studied those quite a bit for the nervous system based stuff where we're
building kind of our own sensory immersion,
like mindfulness room of the future as well.
All the walls led screens.
So you could put yourself fully immersed in any environment.
It's going to be pretty bad ass mindfulness is so overlooked in these sports.
How important,
and I know you're,
you're a meditation guy as well.
It's,
you know,
get getting your mind right.
Is,
is invaluable.
Yeah.
And you were saying that you
meditation and Yoga is also a part of the preparation that you guys employ.
Oh,
100% yeah.
I mean it all comes down to,
you know when we're doing our warm up training and recovery,
it's all mind and body.
So his warmup is going to include like Somata sensory reaction testing.
So imagine like a a wall and it has different lights on it.
You were act as quickly as you can.
As soon as they light up and I say all right,
if the light comes up red,
use your right hand and blue,
use your left hand.
So we're invoking cognitive decision making processes that we need to have.
You stand on one of these shake plates,
appropriate receptive plate.
Now your vision,
your neuromuscular,
your appropriate receptive,
everything is warmed up.
Everything,
every part of your brain that's going to equate to,
you know,
force output,
absorption and so on.
Then we go do a more traditional warmup,
whatever that may be.
We do a cognitive training,
we do physical training more from a functional aspect.
And then as soon as you're done,
we you into a mine based recovery as well.
So we get you into yoga meditation that you know,
technology we're playing with right now that manipulates your biochemicals.
Uh,
you know,
just just about everything man.
It's mind and body every step along the way.
And when you're doing yoga,
you're doing yoga to increase mobility.
Are you doing it for the mental training?
For both?
Like,
um,
definitely a little bit of both.
We believe I'm Andre more leads that the yoga what,
what we're doing over there.
So He'd be better to ask specifically,
but we believe it largely for nervous system and for breathing.
Uh,
one thing we really talked about is the diaphragmatic breathing and yoga is
really a calm environment to be able to focus on your breathing.
What does that mean?
Diaphragmatic breathing?
Yeah,
breathing from your diaphragm.
This is how we're all born.
Breathing from our diaphragm and just,
you know,
eventually we ended up breathing from our chest,
which is very ineffective for metabolic efficiency.
And Jennifer,
just like when you see like the Wim Hoff Guy,
he's what was breathing from his gut here and that's like engaging your core as
opposed to just like your chest.
So you're actually getting deeper breaths.
You're encouraging like core stability and things as well.
It's better for metabolic efficiency.
So when you're actually exercising it's better for delaying anaerobic threshold,
buffering lactate,
things like that as well as keeping the nervous system calm as well.
Do you think there's any benefit to breathing through your nose and out through
your mouth?
Or is that,
um,
I,
I'd say it's an on an individualized basis.
I think if it,
the best thing is to not think about your breathing when you start thinking
about it,
it can kind of get fucked up.
So if we encourage diaphragmatic breathing without this,
this technology we utilize is actually,
even though when you're utilizing the technology,
you're just breathing in and out through your mouth,
it actually encourages in through the nose,
out through the mouth when you're training.
So I'm,
I mean I'm not an expert specifically on that,
but it sounds,
yeah,
I think there's definitely some performance advantage to it.
Oh,
I want to talk to him.
He may know Joe.
Thank you Kevin.
I appreciate him and this guy will,
he goes,
go,
go on all day.
Kevin.
Thank you so much for those,
those amazing of course,
but where they could find out about your company and what your website is.
Uh,
our company's in Scottsdale,
Arizona.
The website is neuro force one o n e.com.
Check us out.
All right,
thank you.
Thanks chef.
Those are very informative,
intense shit.
Son Henry is now become the standard because uh,
like he said that a Roman for the performance institute debt did that PowerPoint
presentation for UFC Moscow.
He told us he's the first athlete that ever did eight weeks that they have eight
weeks collection of data.
So Henry's now become the standard of the system that a Roman had newer force
one and all the data put together as the first time ever that an athlete
actually stuck to the program for eight weeks.
That's fantastic.
So for you now you got the title and there is talk about you fighting for the
bantamweight title against champion Tj Dillashaw.
What are your thoughts?
Where are you at right now?
Like what are you,
what are your goals?
It's,
it's a beautiful town of [inaudible] to be the champ.
There's a,
there's,
there's tons of tons of options.
Joe,
where's your contract out right now?
Oh,
uh,
I have,
I still about seven fights
left,
you know,
but,
uh,
I'm under,
I'm,
we're going to renegotiate because I think more than likely that TG five might
might happen.
Gonna happen that TG fight might happen if,
you know,
if it's going to be a dumb with,
with uh,
with the flyweight division.
You know,
I think the cat's out the bag and you know,
they didn't have had mentioned that to me,
so,
hey,
you know,
we were going,
we want to take you up on that offer a view,
a challenging to go up against Tj,
but this is what,
this is where the company's been thinking about for awhile and teachers down for
it too.
I don't think so.
I think TJ wants to come down to 25 I think.
I think that's Kinda like the,
like the delay a little bit.
Yeah.
Now,
would you rather fight him at 35 so you can get an additional title or would you
rather fight him at 35 because you don't have to cut weight or what's your head?
I don't,
I like both ideas.
I actually kind of left it off to him.
I said,
sir,
I don't know,
but I want to fight you,
man.
I said,
I wanna fight Tj.
I want to,
I want to go out to the next best thing.
And that's,
I think that's him,
you know,
if you don't mind fighting for 25 or 35 yeah,
I don't,
that makes it easier.
Yeah,
that definitely makes sense.
I'm just like,
Hey,
let's,
let's see it at 25 listed at 35,
but let's,
uh,
let's fight man.
That's what your,
your mind is right now.
That's your number one goal.
Yeah.
And I believe Tj wants to fight me too.
I think,
uh,
you know,
beating Demetrius,
I think they kind of,
that's going to help his name and you know,
you know,
I guess for both you can sit,
so now that Demetrius has left the division and gone off to one fc to get
where I'm,
where do you think the division is right now?
I mean,
I,
um,
is that one reason,
like if you won at 35 and one of the title 35,
would you consider dropping the 25 pound title and competing at 35 or would you
rather stay at 25?
Ah,
I would,
I wouldn't mind.
I wouldn't mind dabbling in both.
I mean,
I know that's a,
that's Kinda,
that's kind of broad,
but I won't point.
You do get tired of cutting weight and I'm kind of a,
anyway,
right now I'm probably about probably about 50,
50.
You don't wonder,
I mean,
losing 15 pounds is way better than losing 25 pounds.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm a little,
I'm a little bigger now,
uh,
because of,
because of that reason I might,
I might have to fight at a bad time,
so I'm kind of a,
I think more like him,
it might happen at bat him away.
What people don't know is that actually Henry almost fought TJ when he was the
champ when Hannah Borow didn't make weight his first fight in the UFC.
He didn't make weight.
But two hours later Hanan Barao didn't make,
make weight and they were looking for somebody to go up and fight TJ when Joe
Soto Fordham [inaudible] was the number one option.
But Henry had already declined.
Uh,
he said he wasn't fighting Jorgensen and,
but now here we are three years later back now he's got the tent,
he's got the belt.
Tj came back and won the belt was do it.
These guys been beefing for uh,
for a long time.
So ever since the first day he came into the UFC,
him and Tj have been added.
And then on the ultimate fighter,
ultimate fighter 24,
they had a Duane bang was the coach.
There was like a little beef with Henry and,
and uh,
Benevidez his team Benevidez his coach.
So it Kinda goes way back
there.
There's a bit of animosity to,
on top of everything.
Now you are very goal oriented guy.
Do you,
uh,
do you have your career mapped out in terms of like when you would like to get
out of the game?
Oh my do.
I do and I think about it a lot cause man,
I,
I'll be honest with you Joe,
I've,
uh,
I've accomplished everything I've ever wanted to,
you know,
and in my career,
like I've always,
I had,
I had three goals and I was just,
you know,
my number one goal was just to be a good person,
that good father and a good husband.
And then after that we'll say being an Olympic champ and then,
and then,
and then eventually UFC champs.
So everything's kind of,
uh,
I,
I've,
I've done everything in that I've ever kind of set my mind to,
you know,
those are the two biggest things,
the two magnets to get anybody to get everything.
And,
uh,
I,
I don't see myself fighting for more than for more than maybe three to four
years.
The only collagen woods,
you really are in this rare space where you have the possibility of being
considered one of the greatest combat sport athletes of all time when you're
already in the mix.
Right.
The Olympic gold medalist,
UFC champion.
I mean,
you,
you have this very rare opportunity for incredible greatness.
Yeah.
I think for the most part,
I mean,
I like to eventually,
I do a lot of motivational speaking.
Uh,
I've been doing that for a while.
Joe Is spoken in front of like the biggest,
the biggest companies in the world.
I mean,
the Coca Cola,
like the TD Ameritrade,
Procter and gamble,
your billion dollar come.
I just got soundbite Kroger.
Um,
and,
and they kind of,
you know,
they use me for,
for that reason.
I really enjoyed doing that.
And,
and plus you get put off of a book page
and you don't have to get leg kicked.
Yeah.
You don't have to get leg kick and hit that nerve and do the drunken monkey.
You don't gotta do all that and it's just cool.
It just call to kind of share the,
the,
you know,
the whole underdog story.
I love that people do do that.
The companies have the,
the,
the mindset of bringing in champions and people that are extraordinary or
whatever they do,
and speaking to these,
you know,
these people that work for them and explaining like,
what did,
I mean that motivation is gigantic.
Motivation is such a huge source of fuel for people in all walks of life.
You know,
to have a guy like you come in and talk to a company could have a really big
impact on their creativity on,
on how they pursue goals on all kinds,
all kinds of different fit things.
Yeah.
So that,
that's,
so anyways,
that's kind of where I kind of,
I can see my life kind of heading to now.
I know eventually I don't think I can,
I don't think,
I think I'll always be a fan of the sport,
but I don't think I'll be involved in either rustling or fighters as much as I
think I would
not as a coach.
Not as,
no,
it's too hard Joe.
Like,
look at all these because these coaches,
it's a two relationship.
Yeah.
You know,
being a coach is you're,
you're in a relationship with,
uh,
with your athletes.
Sometimes you go through these breakups and sometimes the athletes don't give
you what they want to give you and then it's just a,
it's a headache at times.
Yeah.
And they see that with,
I see that with a lot of,
you know,
I see that with him and I'm just like,
man,
I don't know if I want those stress level.
Well,
Eric,
for a guy like you,
you,
you get across a guy like Henry,
you hit the gold mine,
but you could get across the guy who is a really talented guy that's a flake.
And those two,
to me personally,
there's plenty of those.
But to me as an analyst,
as someone to watch his fights there,
the most frustrating because there's some guys that I see and I'll go,
God damn,
that motherfucker is good.
And he's got to potential.
Like they can do things inside the octagon.
They do things like I'll see guys in the gym,
like I'll go to a gym and watch guys train and see the guy and I go,
if this motherfucker could put it together like this in the cage,
the way you see when he's sparring.
Like some people are just artists,
but the anxiety of competition and,
and all the factors that come involve the discipline,
the consistency,
all the things that make someone a great fight or sometimes there's so much,
so many different things that make someone a great fight or that at wind up
fucking them up when when they,
they actually go to compete though the recklessness and impulsiveness that
actually makes them good also can wind up tanking them if they don't sort of
forge it with,
with,
with some sort of like severe disease
plan.
Yeah.
There,
there has to be a training of the mind too.
And I think that's where people are skipping.
And uh,
you know,
I think that's,
that's where you had to understand like the philosophy appeared like you have
to,
you have to be right up top.
You have no right to be yet to be literally,
you have to understand and know who you are as a fighter,
as a person.
And uh,
you know,
to kind of,
to be stable enough to perform at,
uh,
when,
when it really matters,
you know?
And if,
if you don't have that,
you can be as talented and as gifted as you want,
you'll,
you'll never make it.
Yeah.
And then we'll see those all the time.
Like I'd see guys in practice mad,
they would tear me up and they came to a competition.
There was just a rollover rollover like fish.
It's weird,
right?
Yeah.
It's crazy.
I'm like,
Huh.
Yeah.
It's weird.
As you're coming up and you see those guys and you're,
you realize like,
man,
there's,
there's something missing and then you,
you,
you're terrified.
You're going to see that in yourself.
In ethic is the embracement of embracing pressure is something that you don't
neglect or sometimes she don't shy away from something that you don't allow them
to damage you,
but it's an embracement.
It's a,
it's just like,
hey,
bring it man.
Bring me,
cause that's what it is,
Joe.
It's the pressure that people feel,
the reason why they can't perform.
It's what makes champions.
I remember when Tj Dillashaw first fought Hanan Barao um,
when he got into that octagon,
he looked like he was born,
he was loose as a goose.
And I,
and I saw him,
I'm like,
Damn,
look how loose TJ is.
Like this is a world title fight.
And he's switching stances and giving them looks and he looks fantastic.
He just looked loose and then boom,
he hits him with that big overhand right.
And next thing you know,
Henry Morales getting fucked up.
I mean,
and that was what TJ thrives on.
That kind of pressure.
He lives for that kind of pressure just like you do,
which is why I want to,
yeah,
let's do it.
I want his head on the,
I want to say I went to his head on a spike.
I wanna I wanna make,
I wanna make some snake shoes out of
snakeskin snake skin shoes,
navy suit.
I think he might be big enough for me.
You know what a fight that would be for fans too.
I mean it's those champion versus champion encounters are always so fantastic.
No,
and the reason why it's cool too is because we're both in our prime to like,
Tj is probably a couple of years older than me.
But even when like the matress like dude,
I'd be Demetrius in his prime.
Like yeah,
it was a close fight.
But man,
I can say,
did I,
I beat him in his prime in this prime.
It's almost like there's no doubt.
But it was,
it was because of the game plan.
And then you ended the greatest winning streak in the history of the sport.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Rich Championship defense streak in the history of the sport.
And then on top,
I mean number good.
Madoff has the greatest winning streak in the sport because he's,
you know,
still undefeated.
But as far as defending the title,
Dj was number one.
And again,
you did it to him in his prime.
If you look at the way he destroyed Wilson Hayes,
if you look at like,
I mean fucking give it just everybody.
Man,
everybody just,
he's a monster,
a Borg,
the greatest submission.
And that was his three shit of all time.
We fucking suplexes him and it catches an arm bar on the way down.
Get the fuck Outta here.
They told me he does that and training all the time.
Yeah.
Matt Hume is a wizard a,
where's it?
One of the things that I did that was kind of unconventional,
unconventional for this camp.
I had them video at it.
We obviously we scouted Demetrius Johnson,
but then I went back and got every one minute clip of Matt Hume's,
uh,
interval between rounds.
So 25 fights.
I have the one minute what he tells him how he adapts and changes.
And one of the things I noticed is that he always went to wrestling and he went,
he always went to wrestling.
He sounded like it was automatic.
All right,
so this round we're going to take him down and we're going to work.
It was always automatic and when it went into the fifth round,
it wasn't automatic.
You can hear him say,
you could try to take them down if you want.
It was kind of like that,
the way he said it.
And when I went back and watched and I was like,
we got him.
And,
uh,
going into that fifth round,
one of the things that we talked about subliminally and mentally,
uh,
training was when we went,
Henry was just putting the hall of fame,
you know,
he,
which has never been done at such a young age as a wrestler,
as a wrestler.
And when was at the wrestling hall of fame,
Nate car,
who's also one of the greatest Russell's ever,
he told me,
he said,
you know what,
Eric,
when I wrestled Kenny Monday and I lost him in the big tents,
I knew that when I went out two weeks later to fight him in the Ncaa finals,
that it might come up that,
that,
that band,
this guy just beat me.
And he goes,
so I had a book,
actually,
I think he said his wife made his book.
Uh,
and he put all the positive things that,
that,
um,
made car had done and all the articles,
and she made quotes from that and put it in this book.
So he gave me that idea and then I did that.
So when Henry was putting in the hall of fame that night,
they had a video highlights.
It had Terry brands is coach.
They had a circuit.
Bella,
I've Kenny,
Kevin Jackson,
some of the greatest,
all his coaches saying stuff about him when I took that and I put it in his book
and it kind of like when I read it to him every day and they kind like,
uh,
happened in the fight.
One of the pieces are own quotes would said,
I've got to go in there and kill and be ready to die.
And,
and you know,
when he got that leg injury,
you know,
he was ready to die.
He was ready to keep going forward.
Yes,
we adapted and it went south pole.
But I'll,
some of that stuff from the book came exactly true.
Start fast and,
and finish even stronger,
compete with passion and a purpose.
And this was when I said to him right here and the fifth day to show you this
does,
this is what I told him going into the fifth round,
uh,
when we was forward,
let's see the two,
let's see that's here.
Shit,
let me say as said less throw Henry,
burn the ships,
take the fucking castle,
let's take him down.
Hurt him on the ground.
If he gets back up,
knock cause it has out.
And that's what I told him going into the fifth round,
the Shaker.
We,
I've actually only had one or two,
but we should say the Messenger.
So,
uh,
you know,
it's just uh,
something that I was ingrained into them every uh,
every sparring session.
I had something set for him.
But this time going into the fifth round against Dj,
I wasn't sure if it was two to two or if he needed a knockout.
Did you feel,
I thought it was two to two.
And I think,
I think,
I think Dj from the interviews that I've heard,
I think he felt like it was too to going into the fifth year.
We thought it was too too when we were watching the football boy.
Damn,
this is as close as it gets.
Which makes,
yeah.
And again,
Joe,
I wouldn't,
like I said,
I,
I it because it was such a close fight.
Dude.
I,
I had a clap for Demetrius too.
If they would've gave them though the fight.
I know it was close,
you know?
Um,
what did you weigh?
I was actually,
I was actually a pound lighter than,
uh,
than the beaches.
I don't know if she knew it.
Yeah,
you look bigger.
it really did.
But that's again,
that's,
that's kind of just one that's kind of where they,
the way they placed like my muscle,
like it was a,
that's why I look bigger,
but not always a pound lighter than Demetrius Johnson.
Didn't you wear at night?
That one 41.
Oh Wow.
This kid's,
when you sigh,
you guys standing together in the octagon,
you really did look bigger than him is really interesting.
Yeah.
Yeah,
so I'm not,
I was,
I was letting Demetrius people if I die
and he kept on saying,
he said it twice.
He's so big.
He's so strong.
He said it twice in this post interview,
but that's wrestling strength,
right?
Wrestling's traits.
It's just a different kind of strength.
Where did it,
sometimes it's just not even his strengths and leverage.
Learn how to use,
how to,
how to tippy toe things and how to use your weight to,
to pressure opponent or to take them down
two for sure,
but there's also strength strength that wrestlers have.
Anybody's ever roll with a or knows that.
Yeah,
I guess.
Sure.
I get to see the transformation that he had from the eight weeks,
from the beginning to the aunt Ma.
There's a documentary.
These guys filmed the whole entire thing and you guys are amazing.
You're putting the documentary on.
Yeah,
we're going to put it,
yeah.
I think we're going to put it off sometime in the,
I think in the spring,
but it's going to come out in the beginning.
It's going to be,
it's going to be not,
I think we're going to try to pitch it to a,
to Netflix.
Nice.
Yeah.
He holds across the Messenger.
The lesson.
And they'll forget,
uh,
as not only was he fighting for the title,
this guy was fighting for his life only eight months before in the Santa Rosa
fires.
So his story is very inspirational.
That's a crazy fucking story in and of itself.
You actually burn the bottom of your feet running,
escaping a fire that snuck up on you.
Like lightning speed,
Huh?
Yeah,
it was,
it was a,
it was the craziest thing that's probably ever happened to me and I've done some
crazy things.
Yeah.
They documented it in the UFC pre show,
like they showed like all the damage to the area where you were living.
It's fucking terrifying.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
I,
uh,
at anyways,
I mean,
I guess,
I guess this is where people kind of share their stories,
right.
But it's,
ah,
yes.
So this was about a year ago now,
so this was,
yeah,
about a year ago now.
And I got invited to this event with a,
you know,
raising,
raising money for kids in cancer.
And everybody in there,
every,
every big celebrity gets invited like cherry your rise,
like Barry bonds,
like the,
the big aid list,
celebrities and everybody was there and that we had a fundraiser that night and
you know,
wine country in Santa Rosa,
California,
you know,
and everybody knew.
Everybody had their drinks and whatnot.
You know,
I had,
I had a couple of glasses,
maybe had a few glasses of wine,
but I don't,
I don't drink wine,
but I had a few glasses and I remember I told her,
but hey,
I'm going to sleep guys.
And it was close to about midnight.
I was like,
I ain't trying to stay up with these people and I'm trying,
I'm trying to sleep cause I was,
I never drink wine.
So I go to my room and uh,
and then I shower,
get into bed and,
and uh,
I remember right before I went to bed,
I remember I saw like the flickering of lights and I just,
I got that it was weird.
This is roughly about time.
I got to my hotel,
I shout,
I saw the flicker of light side.
I didn't think anything of it.
And uh,
I,
I pass out to 30 hits,
two 30 in the morning,
head to,
and I'm just,
uh,
I'm just,
you know,
I wake up because I hear the alarm,
kind of pop off at the,
at the hotel.
So now I'm hearing these alarms starting to go off and I've,
you know,
I checked out,
I checked out on,
uh,
through the window and I checked out the lobby.
Nobody was moving.
So I was like,
it's a false alarm.
So I grabbed the pillow,
put over my head and every can slept to the alarm.
That happened about two 30.
Now four 30 comes about.
And this time I don't wake up.
I don't wake up because the alarm,
I wake up because of the smoke and my coffee and I'm,
I'm like coffee on the small and efforts.
I thought I was dreaming.
So I wake up and I,
at that time I had,
I had,
uh,
you know,
I slept in my town.
That's how tired I was and I got up and I'm going to turn the lights and the
light tank turning down and then I go through the window and a check the window
and next,
you know,
and I see the car right in front of me on fire.
Uh,
three fourths of the hotels,
like I was probably about five rooms away from like getting hit hard.
Like I'm talking about like,
like fire coming out the window and like that.
And I'm waking up to this,
like thinking I'm dreaming,
you know,
in a towel.
And then the lights,
everything was dark,
but I could see everything like it.
Like the room started getting hot and I couldn't,
I couldn't hold my breath the more I started looking for my shoes.
I couldn't find my shoes and I bumped into my slacks that I left them on the
ironing board that the night before and I put them on and I,
I grabbed,
I grabbed the,
I grabbed my phone and I jumped out the window.
I jumped out the ones that jumped out the wound on my right foot catches on
fire.
All right.
Foot catches on fire fast and I'm looking to kind of,
I'm Kinda,
you know,
trying to put it out and it's crazy how I can see how people could catch on fire
real quick.
Cause my,
my right leg was like food.
It was crazy.
Wow.
So I jumped out and I started walking as I'm walking them seeing like this,
the hotel in front of us was all in sticks to like the whole thing was just in
sticks.
Like the fire had just ate that thing up.
There's a building in front of me on,
on fire.
Like,
I'm just walking through the streets,
going up the hill and just thinking like,
God give me a horrible way to die.
Horrible way to die.
Fuck.
And I got to,
I got a bird's eye view when I was on top of the,
uh,
when I was on top of the hill.
And then I saw there as a cop down there,
there's a cop down,
uh,
and in the middle of the free ones,
just like we know that's where I got to go.
So now I'm running fast and I've seen that this brush fire kind of come along
and just,
I'm seeing like California,
like just catch on fire,
like completely like through my eyes.
I jump over the first fence to get to the freeway,
you know,
no problem.
I jump over the second fence and then the third fence,
it was a,
it was a very like a flimsy,
a kind of fence.
And I remember I,
as I,
as I jumped out in British snag,
like part of my snacks,
I keep in mind,
I was,
I had,
the only thing I had on was slacks.
I W I got what's commando slacks,
no shirt,
no shoes,
like out in the cold in California.
And as I,
that flimsy fence as a,
as I jumped out that last fence,
it like cut it like a part of the fence.
I grabbed my butt and it just,
it cut me open heart and a tour,
like half the leg.
So now I'm full,
I'm full of smoke and my right foot is burned and uh,
um,
I'm pretty much half naked it with a for you.
So I see the cop car and I go up to the cop car and as I'm going up to it,
I'm sorry,
the freaking cop car leaves like fucking just scrambles and just like,
oh my God.
In as soon as that cop car left,
uh,
I remember seeing like this big as diesel,
like coming towards me and ever get into the middle of the freeway and Kinda,
you know,
waving my hands,
like,
you know,
take me,
I die like this,
like hit me dude.
And uh,
as it got closer,
so it was a fire truck and I,
and I get rescued.
I get rescued by the fireman.
They put me in the fire truck and they're just kinda like looking at him.
He's like,
down,
do you just,
you just survived death.
You just survived deck.
Because I was black dude.
I said,
I already smelled like a marshmallow.
Did anybody die in the hotel?
50 50 50 people died in a,
sorry,
the whole time.
I'm not sure if anybody died at the hotel.
I hope not.
But I could see how 50 people died in the,
yeah,
it was,
it was a worst.
No,
you have 50 people died.
50 families like it was,
it was,
it was sad to hear what just happened quick.
Those fires come so quick.
People don't realize it's before it's too late.
And then there's no escape route.
And I think the reason why it's,
I think people have time to get out.
And I think the reason why 50 people dad is because they didn't take the,
the,
the alarm like me serious.
And next you notice this too late because that,
that smoke will blind you.
So you think you're going to into the right direction and next,
you know,
you're walking into the biggest fire in history.
Jesus Christ.
So,
so that had happened like two months before I fought Sergio [inaudible] and I,
and I,
and I still fought on like I trained with two socks just with the,
with the,
with the wrestling shoe and I just stuck it out because,
uh,
I pulled out the first fight with them.
I says,
I,
I gotta make it up to you.
And I told him,
I says,
Hey,
I,
I said,
I owe you want her.
Then he kind of called me out on it.
I was like,
Ah Dude,
I'm going to fight your regardless now man with,
with,
with a,
with a first degree burns on my foot or I'm sorry,
a third degree burns on my foot.
Wow.
Well I'm glad you made it,
man.
Yeah,
the hero.
I,
yeah,
2018 a UC chin.
I'm glad he made it and I'm glad we could do this podcast.
Thanks for doing this,
man.
I really appreciate it.
Yeah,
no,
for sure thing.
Thank you Joe.
I've been a been a big fan of your show and,
uh,
hope you guys got some good insight on the Messenger and can captain America
over.
We certainly did.
We definitely did.
And Kevin as well.
Yeah.
Well thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Bye everybody.